The joe rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
My night all day.
Oh,
hello.
Sweet pitches.
That's right.
We're back with the cast of kill Tony the mat.
What would you be?
The composer.
What's a maestro?
The Maestro of kill Tony Young Tony Hinchcliffe.
Thank you.
Hello.
Uh,
young and beautiful.
Sarah wan Shank and young and beautiful.
Kimberly condom.
Hi there.
Hello everybody.
Yeah,
if you guys don't know the show,
it's a podcast on the desk squad podcast network where these two gals
courageously for over a year have done a whole new minute of standup every week,
which takes fucking mad testicles that you don't possess.
It's not courage,
intestinal fortitude.
Um,
but my point is you guys,
you guys did something that I don't think anybody's ever done in that you've
documented your entire standup comedy career.
Right?
Is it true both of you,
all of your sets were on it or did any of you do sets before that?
I did sets.
But you did sets before you did all of your sets on the show.
Yeah.
My first night at the comedy store,
uh,
was my,
the,
my first night going up was on killed.
Tony Dunne is so crazy.
Yeah.
That's so crazy.
And you've been doing that for how long now?
Uh,
about a year and four months now.
That's every week.
Is that your first time ever on stage right there?
No,
that's us.
Uh,
a few weeks ago.
Is that Sarah Kim?
I can't see.
It's all blurry.
It's Sarah.
It's Dave Attell and Jimmy Schubert.
Powerful.
Sarah,
look at you up there.
Rep Dance.
That's a check.
I love those pants.
No girl would ever look at a picture of herself and go,
God,
I love those pants.
Or no dude.
Rather point being,
um,
if I had to go back and watch my old standup comedy,
I'd probably throw up,
I'd probably have a heart attack.
I'd probably be like,
oh my God,
I'll never be able to do this.
Like I sucked so hard.
I'll never be able to make it.
But you,
you,
you fucking ballsy chicks have done,
I can't,
I need a better word.
All the luggage.
It's true though,
but it is ballsy.
Whatever it has me.
You guys have fucking done some crazy shit.
I mean doing that in front of every like every week doing a whole new minute of
standup comedy.
Yeah,
it takes a lot.
It's hard and especially now we're getting into like over 80 weeks and so you're
like squeezing out every little bit of anything funny that happened.
Do you go back and like capture your,
the stuff he did in the earlier episodes and tried to turn it into like a longer
bit?
Yeah.
Well sometimes I'll,
I'll,
I'll listen to the older ones and I'll be like,
what else can I talk about and make new like tags and I'll just use those tags
as my new joke.
Yeah,
no,
I too,
I totally get it.
Yeah.
Kill Kill.
Tony is a podcast that Tony Hinchcliffe started with Brian and you guys figured
out a really delicious plan and it's have comics go up for a minute.
Just a minute.
You a minute of standup and then you have pros just either say,
hey,
that was really funny.
Like that bullets and bricks guy.
We were like,
hey,
fucking good shit dude.
You could really be a calm,
I click you're a comic work at this and you can be a comic.
Or you know,
like some people like,
oh my God,
what was this craziness that I just saw her?
Right.
And you get a chance to see like the professional comics fuck with these people
or you know,
get excited about seeing someone who's funny.
Yeah.
It's like if you hang out in the back of the original room a lot where you know,
normal standup comedy takes place or any comedy club,
you'll always see a bunch of comedians in the back either standing around or
sitting down and they're always whispering something in each other's ears.
And that I always thought found that that to be some of the most interesting
stuff is getting,
you know,
more pros,
comedian perspective on what's happening in front of them.
Sometimes they're like,
this person's going to be a star.
And sometimes it's like,
wow,
I can't believe this guy didn't iron his shirt before coming out.
And that wide range of conversation that happens between experience comedians
watching newer comedy is always entertaining.
And I figured,
how do we turn that into a spontaneous podcast that is refillable so people sign
up and there's a big bucket and people get a new minute.
Some people travel from around.
We've had,
we just had somebody on the traveled from Scotland to do kill Tony for his first
time on stage and so fuck you all right,
Australia every week it's somebody new.
So people like literally rather than doing a bigger set somewhere else,
they'll purposefully start on kill Tony because they listened to that show and
that's what made them realize or gave them the inspiration that they'd like to
at least try to do this thing that they've always inside one or to do.
So.
It's really fun getting to give people that opportunity and have them be excited
about it and inspired.
Okay.
It's fun to do too.
I did it with dom Irrera and we had the fucking best time.
It was so much fun.
And I think that one of the things that I've been thinking about lately,
like because I did my special and I threw out all my material and I'm starting
off with all new material,
I have to write a lot and I'm just like in this like frantic,
frenzied mode.
One of the things,
it's really good,
it's like watching other people sort of like try to piece it together and then
talking about like what was wrong with that?
Why didn't that like,
what's an in,
in doing that you kind of do some stuff that you ordinarily probably don't do
much with your stand up.
Like a lot of comics,
they record their sets,
very few listen to those sets,
right?
Most guys just record them and then just go fuck that and just,
and just keep going for whatever reason.
But when you're forced to analyze your stuff,
like I did a,
you know,
Ari has that podcast,
uh,
the skeptic tank and every now and then he'll do an episode with a comic and
I'll play a CD and you have to go over the CD.
And I went over the CD and as I was going over and I was like thinking about all
kinds of things.
It was an old CD.
I hadn't listened to it and like six years and as I was listened to us,
like there's like a lot of shit in here.
I would do different or nice.
See how I did that then,
oh Ooh,
I used to do that better.
Like I had this bit,
you know,
and you start thinking like you can actually listen.
If you listen to yourself from six years ago,
you could actually listen to yourself.
Like as an outsider,
like I know that it's me,
I recognize the voice,
but I barely remember the material cause it's so long ago.
Yeah,
yeah.
About a month ago,
buddy came up to me or not even a buddy,
it was just a random guy and he goes,
man,
I saw you like five or six years ago.
You did that one joke about this thing and I totally forgot that I did it.
Come to completely.
And I got so excited because I hadn't heard that had anybody on kill Tony or
another comedian came up with this premise,
I would have gone,
that's a great premise by the way,
just want to let you know,
I love what you're doing with the blank and blank thing.
You know what I mean?
And I was so excited because it was like he gave me this gift that was just
something that I did anyway that I didn't remember that I did from five or six
years ago.
But that crazy enough is the joke that he remembered me from this open mic from.
So it was amazing because yeah,
the perspective is different.
The joke that I do now off that thing is totally different because I came with
uh,
a fresher,
more educated.
I'm more knowledgeable of who I am,
so I know how I really want to do that joke that the fresh me,
Kate wrote the premise for it.
Right,
right,
right.
That's interesting though.
Yeah,
that's really cool.
In their house.
I've had that happen a couple of times.
When people come to you and they remind you of a bit and then you're like,
oh shit.
Or sometimes,
you know,
I,
I listened to probably half of my recordings,
I don't listen to all of them,
but I'm pretty diligent.
If I know that I got a bunch of new stuff out,
I'll listen to it.
But every now and then I'll listen to one and I'll go,
oh,
I forgot.
Oh my goodness,
I forgot that part.
And that part like makes everything way better.
Exactly.
Where that part takes it in another direction.
Yeah.
Every little,
every little thing that you can add on when once you're already in a topic,
it's a huge gift because it,
not only is it just one show,
but once it,
once it's ingrained in the actual thing,
that means thousands and thousands of people are all going to have that laugh.
Yeah.
I mean every show,
once it's part of the thing and especially it only gets better.
So once it's a really working,
yeah,
they become like little living organisms and the more you feed them and more
attention to give them,
the bigger they grow.
And sometimes you have to abandon them.
Like sometimes like,
oh,
this one's just bad.
It's just that it's down a bad road.
I don't know how to do this.
Right.
Like I have bits that never made it to cds,
never made specials and nick,
sometimes they killed and sometimes they didn't.
Sometimes it just doesn't know what the fuck I was doing with them.
Yeah.
You know when you let go,
I don't want to do this anymore.
So just like I'm not married to this just because I've been doing it.
Like you just got to abandon them.
That's what makes it so crazy what you girls are doing it.
Yeah,
because you guys are going up and you're doing a fresh minute every week because
you don't,
you don't get like a developmental cycle when you're putting together a freshman
at every week.
You're just hoping that your ideas are good when you get up there.
I mean you doing your sets like a couple of days before you do kill Tony or like
how many,
when do you write your stuff out?
Oh go ahead.
I write mine all week.
Like I just write down jokes as much as I can all week and then I try to work
them out before,
but sometimes I just pick one and then I just build on it.
When on when you go that podcast and you know that it's live and it's on the
Internet and then you're just going up with this shit that you hope might work,
like what is that feeling like?
It's so scary.
Well,
Sarah,
it's,
Sarah does her as a week before and a lot of the times I write mine,
like the day I'm going in,
I write it and you know what most,
a lot of the times when I write mine the day of are the ones that do really,
really well because then I'm not as nervous and it comes out more natural and
that's another thing I've learned on killed Tony.
Just mostly like stage presence is a huge thing because you have the live
audience too,
right?
You know,
so it's not like you're just doing a minute on just a podcast.
What do you think that means?
Like what does stage presence mean?
Oof.
It's an interesting one in the,
because it means different things to different people.
Right?
Like what,
what exactly does that mean
for me?
Just means like looking confident and calm,
where I don't,
not having the audience being uncomfortable watching you,
right?
Yeah.
That's a big one.
That's a bit longer than you watch someone,
you know,
they're nervous up there.
You're like,
yikes.
Calm down dude.
You know?
Yeah.
And that's what's really cool is,
you know,
the,
the live audience watches the show and they see names being randomly pulled out
of a bucket with 20 or 30 comedians waiting to run from the top and come down
the stairs and be on the show.
You know,
they're going from a viewer to an audience.
They're going from an audience member to a comedian,
to a podcast guest,
and then thrown back out in the belly room again.
So they're uh,
you know,
it's also so cool because they,
these two always go on at the end of each show and every time,
especially even this last episode,
we just had the last comedian that I pulled out of the bucket before I knew I
was going to that part.
It was an unbelievable interview.
Probably one of the biggest,
longest interviews we ever had.
We found out that this kid is living in some big producers house by being half
gay and like half,
like teasing him with things and being cute around the house.
But I'm producing sledding and live in this around the house.
It's unbelievable.
This big producers letting them live in this mansion.
We found out all this stuff and think that nothing can follow that,
but what really does follow it?
And it even surprised me cause I'm like,
man,
I hope that that,
that it goes how it normally goes is they come in,
even though that was crushing,
I had to send them off and go,
all right,
well this is the part of the show where our two regulars go up and sure enough,
right when you thought it couldn't get any better,
they just own it with exactly that thing,
which is that comfortable.
All of a sudden the audience is seeing these two assassins who do this every
week and they can feel it.
Not only did they hear me say it before when I bring them up,
but they,
you can really feel it because if they couldn't feel it,
then they would just go,
wow,
these two,
you know,
I mean the GS,
they do this every week,
but instead it makes,
it's always the best way to close the show.
It wasn't always that way,
by the way.
And that's what really the coolest part is about this whole documentary thing in
my opinion is that yeah,
maybe some of the sets weren't the best of this or that,
but they're,
you know,
not only does the audience get to watch the overall growth for the ones which is
the many,
a lot of the diehard fans,
so many of them,
you know,
talk about that.
When they see me,
like in Toronto when we just did a theater a few weeks ago with this show and so
many people were like,
you know,
getting to watch Kim and Sarah go from how they were to these monsters that you
know,
it's pretty much a guarantee that you're going to hear a brand new set of jokes
that is pretty good and it's going to be a part of something bigger eventually.
So they get the first look at it,
which is cool.
Yeah.
Well you guys are doing is like you're,
you're coming up with new shit.
Like that's like the hardest part of common.
He's coming up with new shit and you're coming up with new shit.
Like as fast as anybody is like a minute a week.
It's about as fast as anybody can do it.
I give you,
if you get lucky,
like every now and then you'll hit like a five minute streak.
Like you got a new chunk and it's five minutes long ago.
Oh,
I hit a gold mine.
You know when you start pulling bits out of it or pulling taglines and and
premises and sidelines on,
and then you'll have one that's like fucking 15 seconds or one that's 20 seconds
here like this.
You can't get a minute.
You know?
If you have to get a minute every week and a minute that you're going to stand
by and that's going to be on the Internet.
Oh,
good luck.
Yeah.
I think me and Sarah Gotten pretty solid at knowing exactly what a minute is
too.
Maybe we end on with 58
it's crazy too.
Now they're the only two.
You know everybody else,
you'll hear the meow of a kitty at 60 seconds to let them know their time's up.
They'll just crushed,
crushed,
crushed and say good night.
And I looked down at the lower left where Brian is the clock and it always is
(575) 085-0960
exactly.
I know exactly what a minute is cause I take Lyft now and they're like you need
one minute to get outside and they'll call me and I'm like,
oh I know I have 20 seconds left.
Like I know a minute.
Does that help at all in bed?
Yeah,
I know exactly.
The dude's like I gave you 30 minutes of fury,
you're like 33 so it was seven and a half.
You're like I know.
Seven and a half minutes.
Yeah.
Well it's also crazy doing like a longer set afterward like cause I'm so used to
these minutes.
So like going back and like just everything was just tighter.
Yeah.
I was going to ask that.
Like what does it like doing like a dude?
What's the longest you guys have done?
Like 25 Oh wow.
What about you?
20 and 2025 and both of you have been,
you've been doing it a little over a year and you've been doing it.
How long it close to three.
Close to three years.
So 2025 minutes that you would like you,
would you put it on a comedy special?
What'd you guys consider doing a comedy special?
I wouldn't put 25 minutes on a car.
I wouldn't put 20 minutes on a comedy special.
I don't know.
I'm comfortable with 15 minutes.
I like really have a,
I think I have a good 15 that's Brian's idea actually to release 15 minutes
specials.
Yeah.
Like every two months release a 15 minutes special and then like in like eight
months you'll have a an hour special.
That's true.
Yeah.
And then yeah.
Increments of comedy.
Yeah.
It's not about it.
And the other cool thing with their thing is that they get to be in front of
those comedians.
Yeah.
You know,
we've met so many people.
Yeah.
It's so cool to get their perspectives to,
well,
the comedy store,
what since I've been gone has grown like a measurably,
it's amazing.
It's such a different environment there.
Like you guys had always said it was a different environment.
Then I started doing sets there.
I was like,
Whoa,
this is so different.
Like the new management staff and the new regime running it there.
So on the ball it's like someone figured out that there's this fucking gold mine
on sunset and a professional management team started handling it.
Right.
I mean that's what it's like.
It's like a real comedy club now except,
but still like flooded with maniacs.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
When I got there,
which was right after you weren't there just slip a couple months after.
Uh,
a lot of those rooms were dark sitting there dark,
especially little take,
let's take it last night for example,
where that main room is just packed to the gills and their show shows going on
though the belly room would set dark most nights in the main room,
especially with sit completely dark if it's just this giant 400 and whatever
seat room that you'd have to walk through to go get the ladder to put new names
on the sign or whatever.
Yeah,
and that's what it was known as,
like that's what was happening.
But now every night,
and there's those,
these cool shows that are coming out.
Same thing with roast battle on Tuesdays.
Like that shows insane Tuesday at midnight.
That changed.
That changed like 70 people's sleep schedules.
Yeah.
People wake up late on Wednesdays now because of it.
Joe Was the show that brought me back.
I did a,
I went to see that the night before our,
he taped a special there and the camaraderie and the fun in the air.
I was like,
oh my God,
this is like nothing else.
Yeah.
This place is like nothing else on earth,
and I just decided like,
oh,
why am I not coming here anymore?
Like this is a stupid,
yeah.
It just became ridiculous.
Like it's really obvious.
It's not the same place.
It's just there's this weird vibe there,
this chaos.
They're like,
you're doing a midnight show.
Okay.
And this place is packed with people and they're just dissing each other and
when they're dissing each other,
people are jumping on the stands and Jeremiah Watkins and all his buddies there,
they have all these different antics that they do in between.
It's fucking hilarious.
And why I was there,
I was like,
wow,
I can't even believe this.
This is really good.
Like what an environment like it,
you could feel like the,
I want to say like the creativity,
the,
the realness,
you could feel the authenticity of the comics that were all hanging out.
Yeah.
And it's all just for us.
You know what I mean?
It's not like anybody's getting paid for that or anything.
Like we're all just trying to crack each other up.
Everybody's playing their,
their role.
And like you said,
when Jeremiah and Shamar neighbors like on separated,
those two guys are monsters.
But when Jeremiah and Joe Margaret near each other,
they tried out do each other.
We always talk about how they're a modern day,
uh,
um,
Pryor and gene wilder.
Like there's something about when those two they have to out goofy each other.
Right,
right,
right.
But when,
when they're together and they're in their clothes where they'd been doing
comedy together for years being goofballs,
but now they finally have a field where they can showcase it.
Dude,
people forget about those prior gene wilder.
Okay.
Those movers were God damn sensational at the time.
They were like the best like comedy team ever.
And for whatever reason it doesn't get discussed that much.
Like,
I enjoyed the shit out of those movies.
I don't know how they hold up today.
Have you seen one recently?
Yeah,
it's been a long time.
Yeah.
I would wonder.
It's sucks when like stuff that you really liked.
Like I watched altered states.
You know that movie altered states about the guy who turns into a monkey in a
sensory deprivation tank is William hurt.
Never saw that.
It was awesome in 1981 in 2014 you fucking just giggle through it.
You're like,
what kind of a piece of shit and my washing,
this is so fucking stupid.
And like I have such great reverence for Richard Pryor and gene wilder.
I would hate to watch something that they did and not enjoy it.
The new Beverly Cinema Theater right around the corner from where I live that
Quentin Tarantino owns is actually playing a two Richard Pryor specials back to
back and a double feature when,
um,
it's uh,
I think Friday,
December 19th.
You can look it up.
New plans send them a.com.
If I'm home,
I want to go to that.
Yeah,
that sounds right.
Imagine that in a movie theater,
$8 double feature.
They do a like $2 popcorn,
$1 sodas.
Why is Quintin Tarantino so cool?
It's unbelievable.
I have a,
I have a theory.
Have you seen him in person?
Yes,
the size of his hell.
I'd never seen him in person,
person,
whatever.
He's capturing and movies and stuff.
The angle on his head is to make it look not as big as it is when you see him in
real life.
Hey,
listen,
not disadvantage.
No,
I'm telling you the reason why he's so cool.
It's because he has four times the brain matter that anybody else does.
Do you think that's what it is?
It it.
It cannot be coincidence.
His head is twice as big as anybody else's in this room.
Like I'm talking like that Joe.
So you think you think there's just more matter in there?
I just find it hard to believe that it's coincidence that the guy with the
biggest head that I've ever seen is also the genius.
Yeah.
He's also like a,
he morphs into like what the people that he's around,
if you ever seen that,
like he was on Howard stern show once and he was interviewed and he was talking
one way and then he was on this all black show.
Yeah.
And he was being interviewed and it was,
you were just like,
oh no,
the Ab,
he fucking hammed it up so hard that I was like holding on my pants pockets.
Like cringing like,
no,
don't do this.
No,
pull it out,
start talking white again.
Start talking about it again.
But I mean he was like,
yeah,
so we was,
we was doing this thing,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's so ridiculous.
Like have you seen it?
No.
You want to say it?
Yeah,
pull it up Brian,
because it's so ridiculous.
I guess we'll watch it on this thing so we don't get pulled from youtube.
Take a shot if you're playing the drinking game,
podcast pulled from Youtube.
Um,
but,
and again,
all due respect,
Quentin Tarantino,
I don't know the most respect.
Maybe that's what he really talks like.
And you can only be free around black people.
It's white people.
Yes.
To Square it up cause we just don't understand.
You guys don't get it.
Please.
I just love the fact that he's so into film too.
You know,
he was talking about that about like doing things on actual film and that the
look of film,
well that's why he's making the lineups now at this theater.
Like he's owned the theater for years.
That's always been a thing.
Like it's like,
hey that's Quentin Tarantino's theater.
But a few months ago he went in and the guy,
I guess that ms managing it or whatever,
put it in the new projector and he goes,
what's this like state of the art projector?
And the guy's like,
ah,
yeah,
cool.
Right?
And he's like,
not cool.
You're done.
Goodbye.
I'm making the lineups now you're out of here.
Something to that effect.
And so he makes the actual,
like the movies that play these double features at his theater now are the
movies that he would want to see.
So does he like edit them and splice them and stuff like that and put them in
the reels?
Like it's,
is it one of those real to real things like the old school ones,
he doesn't go reel to reel.
He puts a five minute and then her mission,
an old school thing that says five minute intermission pops up
and then he up the other second reel on.
Right.
Wow,
whoa.
These are all the movies that inspired him and like you,
there's probably little things that you know he uses,
pays homage to and things.
And another cool thing is the previews before these newbies or the previous that
for other of his mood for other movies that are playing there later that month.
So you get to see the cool like 1980 preview for blank and blank,
like whatever you get to see.
I saw one when I went to see unbreakable a couple of weeks ago,
uh,
for this Richard Pryor live and the Prefuse for Richard Pryor live.
The ones that played are insane.
You would never believe these.
So different than any type of Promo.
What do you mean?
Like in what way?
Oh God no.
If that's something you'd have to see to believe.
Like it's just it,
I can't remember exactly,
but it's just crazy.
If you look up like the trailer for a Richard Pryor live,
I think the one for the sunset strip,
like I can't remember exactly what's happening,
but I remember thinking if anybody did a promo for their special like this was
done,
it would be all the talk.
Okay.
I don't know what you mean though.
Like in what way?
Like because every hire you right now.
Yeah.
Here's the Quentin Tarantino talking like black people collect your thoughts.
Tony.
No.
For his,
his unconventional style
when it comes to film making one oh six and please welcome director and Academy
Award Winner Quintero
that
film has to be like one of the most quoted movies in Hollywood with just the
lines and everything.
So you got to give us,
this is one of my questions for you.
Your Cube.
What is the most famous like Yo,
your favorite line from pop fiction?
Uh,
I think probably the most famous line is I'm going to get moody.
Baloney.
I ass.
He says it.
Okay.
How wasn't too bad or pleasing the critics for you?
Oh,
interesting question.
Yeah.
Oh,
um,
well I want to,
I want to please my fans.
I don't want to please the critics that I'm a fans.
Uh,
the critics,
even my fans,
I don't give a damn.
Wow.
That hurts my liver
doing is,
is fulfilling his vision.
You know this,
he's a visionary director for us too,
to have the opportunity to work with.
Okay.
Now I'm not that computer savvy,
so be it a sent me something that I plug into my cheap robot would ever heard.
All right.
Download this.
I don't know how to do that.
For All I know
he might've been doing a character,
mighty said,
you know,
I hate doing these fucking shows.
I'm just going to see how black I can get before somebody stabs me.
Right.
I say it's almost sounds like he's mocking them.
Yeah.
Right.
I think he's just probably,
you know,
a very unusual dude.
So put it on a cassette tape.
Oh
my man.
Yeah.
All right.
Goes the bet awards comes back with Rick Ross.
Look at Sandwich Ross.
And that is not the same expression he has during those capitol one ads anger.
Oh yes,
he is eating shit right there.
He's like,
what?
Looking at Jamie.
Jamie Foxx looks high.
Okay.
Fuck.
That might've just been froze there,
but he looks high as fuck.
[inaudible] on the set that day.
Well,
what happened was,
is that
Batman a hundred black,
gray sweat can lady asked him,
I need a hundred black preachers with a black sir.
Okay,
go over to carry with my little tape.
We're going to plant my own biome.
That's it.
The movie.
Any Hamilton,
we don't have beaten this guy.
One unfortunate incident.
It was a few fortunate,
isn't it?
A few of them out there this and he's a beautiful director.
I'm happy he's alive.
I love his fucking movies.
I'll tell you that man.
That dude make some gangster movies.
His movies are fun as Shit.
If reservoir dogs,
if I'm flipping the channels and reservoir dogs,
come on.
No,
you don't like on cable.
Just randomly.
I get very excited.
Yeah.
It's one of those classics we like.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
That's a God damn classic movie.
Yeah,
pulp fiction.
It's one of the best movies ever.
Totally.
I remember when I went to see it,
I was like,
this is I.
It was like,
it was so next level.
I left the theater.
I was shaking my head like this motherfucker just broke movies.
He just figured out to make a movie where you go back in time and forward in
time and you're following it all and everyone's gets shot in the fucking head
and it's like,
whoa.
It was the greatest movie ever.
If I had to pick like one movies,
my favorite movie of all time,
I think pulp fiction would be on a very short list.
Definitely.
Yeah,
so goddamn good.
It's nonstop.
I loved kill bills.
I love to kill bills.
He it don't,
don't just shit on that guy.
Man.
That's a great video though.
I made a few errors in his time.
You seen this video?
No.
Play it.
Go ahead.
Okay.
This is a him slapping a reporter.
How's it going?
What's going on here?
What's going on?
What's going on here,
but that down.
What's going on here?
What are you doing?
Teachers.
You need to talk to me just for,
just for the what are you doing it?
Log into that again.
Hit me.
She's not just a guy from right
now.
I can't do it.
Yeah.
So cool.
Cause you're filming.
But if that was off I'd be whooping your ass up and down this tree.
Yeah.
Incident.
You know,
just walking around like
crazy quick.
He's in Russia.
Try to buy coffee.
It's a one of those film fest
is one of those.
What the fuck is that?
It's so weird.
It's one of those film festivals that is in the freezing cold.
That is a weird way to approach it.
Dude.
Like Quentin Tarantino just stick a fucking camera in his face.
Yeah,
nevermind.
Okay.
His coffee,
he's a dialogue driven guy.
So when that guy didn't answer his,
what are you filming?
You watched the switch and he goes,
what?
He goes from what is this?
And he's still normal to that guy not answering and his eyes just,
he loses it.
Well there's also that weird moment when like he's trying to play it cool when
the guys go on,
come on.
Go for it was like,
man,
I don't think,
cause you could feel the tension between the two of them.
They just had a physical altercation,
altercation,
but he's still trying to like maintain like social calmness.
It's very weird,
right?
Yeah.
Watching conflict is fucking weird.
It's always weird cause you can like sense like how you would be in that
situation.
Oh Jesus Christ.
This is why people love drama.
They love like feeling it without having to be a part of it.
You know that,
that's why people love movies that are fucking crazy dramatic.
As long as they end happily,
people get like super bummed when movies don't end right.
Because part of us,
when you're watching a movie,
you're somehow or another invested in these people that you're following.
You know?
That's why when they get into conflict,
it's so exciting.
Even though you know it's bullshit.
But when you see real conflict like that,
there's something like weirdly exciting about it,
right?
Yeah.
It is a sick drill.
It's awful.
It fucking makes you tingle.
A blizzard
after an argument,
but he helped you get out of a fucking snow bank.
Do you ever seek death proof?
The one where Kurt Russell plays a stunt man.
It's a serial killer with his stunt car.
No,
that's,
is that a term?
Yeah,
but what happened was grinder.
Yeah.
When they made the,
when they made the double feature,
Rodriguez is movie went first and Terentino's when second and it's tough to
follow an hour and a half long Rodriguez action movie and that's what happened.
And they put it out as a modern day double feature,
but it's sort of buried this movie,
the Terantin oh maid,
you know,
and it's very Tarantino and very cool and almost completely sort of unknown
about compared to his other movies.
Wow.
What's it called?
Death proof.
Kurt Russell.
See those movies?
Because I just like all your saw the commercials for whatever reason or never
got around to seeing them.
Yeah.
It looks like it might be fun to watch,
but I don't know,
man.
I'm going to,
the movies can be so brutal.
Yeah.
You're risking people not talking.
You know,
you're risking it and it happens.
It happens every other time.
Every other time we go to the movie,
someone's just having a fucking converse and the rappers and the popcorn.
I don't understand how popcorn became the fucking movie thing.
It's the loudest food.
She'd be like Jello.
She'd be cello or milkshakes or something.
It's popcorn is just [inaudible] it's true in the bag and everything about
popcorns loud popcorn is like Turkey.
Like how the fuck did it become king of Thanksgiving,
right?
I mean is there any real evidence those motherfuckers reading turkeys?
No.
Why is it this one food,
they may have been eating popcorn for all we know.
Well they didn't.
Their corn was like goofy back then.
Yeah.
You know,
you ever see what old corn looks like?
Like non GMO corn.
It's one of the things that people like,
Ooh Jumo fuck goons scourge GMO.
If you look,
look at what GMO actually is.
Like not,
not just like changing the,
you know,
these plants so that they uh,
they can deal with pesticides better and doing,
they do a lot of weird shit today.
That's like super scientific gene splicing type shit.
But genetically modifying like everything that we eat is like modified.
They've like selectively bred everything that we eat.
Like corn used to be the scrappy little fucking dainty thing and now it's these
big ass Iowa ears,
you know all those,
like our tomatoes,
all of our apples,
like all that stuff's been engineered.
You know,
it hasn't all been done in a lab,
but it's all been like we've,
they've made these crops like very in a specific manner so that they have a
higher yield.
Did you ever see king corn now everybody should see that movie.
It's a freak out.
[inaudible] was the best part in it.
When they should a big hole in the side of a cow and they're just reaching in
there.
That's on,
that's in food inc to have that food bank as well.
Like whenever they want to talk about like feeding cattle grain,
they always show these cows and have these open,
I don't know what exactly they're doing,
but they have these open hole.
Well,
you could literally reach into the cow's stomach so they have a hole on the
outside of their body and you could reach your hand into that hole and actually
pull the food out of this cow stomach.
Did they develop abscesses?
Sometimes from eating grains and eating things that like their body just doesn't
want to process and then they're there.
They're pumping.
I'm filled with fucking antibiotics that just jack and their system up and these
fucking house,
like if you,
if you watch this video and you see this,
this whole in the cow or like you're looking into its stomach,
you're like,
what is wrong with people?
Like what are we doing?
Like what,
how do you,
how is this okay?
Like how is it okay to have a hole in the cow side?
We could reach your hand in and just like it's,
it's that fucked up that it's like its stomach is outside of its body.
See if he could pull that up just so we could see it from,
these guys haven't seen it.
And what does that do?
It,
it makes the,
they do it to treat the cows because the cows start getting,
I think they do it for different reasons,
but I think one of the main ones is that when these cows are eating grains and
they're,
they're getting sick,
they developed these abscesses in their body and um,
I think that's what it is with Kelsey.
That's that.
That's where the cow's stomach is.
It looks like a joke or something.
Like a,
a photo shop.
Yeah.
It's,
but coins in around the edges.
I should know the whole reason why they do it,
but it's one of the main reasons why people are propublic.
He's got his hand in that guys.
Oh my goodness.
It's one of the main reasons why people were like trying to go back to grass fed
beef.
Like if you have grass fed beef,
it's not going to be as juicy.
It's not going to be as fat.
It's not going to be like when you cook a Ribeye,
like a corn fed rib eye.
Oh my goodness.
They're just crackling with fat and it's just,
it's so good.
But that animal's sick.
Like it's not a healthy animal.
It's got that all that fat,
it's body.
What's going on?
It's,
it's this custody.
Oh,
when she's pulling the matter out of the cow's body.
Yeah.
He said they were doing it to help the cow.
I think in that situation,
when they have that out,
that ring on the outside of it and they're reaching into the cow's stomach,
I think they'd do it because the cows Foxville.
If they don't,
I don't understand it totally.
I shouldn't be talking about it,
but whatever it is is bad.
Fucking disgusting.
I was like,
can I just vomit this whole documentary?
King corn was all about corn and how much corn is in our food and they go
through these,
these college kids that go through the supermarket and just start pulling things
off the shelves and recognizing how much of everything has corn in it.
And then they do this,
this test on their own body and their,
it found out their bodies like mostly corn.
Like most of the carbon in their body came from corn or whatever the fuck it
was.
But it's one of those things where you,
you know,
they take you,
yeah.
You can stick his hand in the whole of the whole workout.
You son of a B Hinchcliffe yeah,
it's a,
I dunno,
it's,
it's a very
weird thing,
but you can just stick your hand in to someone's,
some animal stomach like,
yeah.
It looks like a piggy bank saying like the circle.
Yeah.
It's a piggy cow I think.
So point being that's no,
you know,
that's uh,
it's not good.
Not Great.
That corn shit's not good for cows.
Oh,
so how,
how many shows do you guys got in the can now?
82 82 kill Tony.
So you girls have 82 minutes of comedy.
Does anybody ever called in sick?
No.
Damn fucking powerful workers.
Yeah.
You guys dedicated?
Not once.
No period talk.
No,
no,
no.
One time I was in a flight back home and that was when we first started.
Yeah.
I was just back home and I missed one and I even tried to record a set and send
it in.
I remember that.
Have you guys gone anywhere else in the country?
Like other cities?
Um,
we've gone to San Diego and we did pass it.
Dina,
did you guys do kill Tony in San Diego or did you do stand up?
We didn't get downtown San Diego.
I know you did it in Pasadena.
Yeah,
comedy store.
La Jolla here.
That's the other thing that's weird about doing comedy in La.
Like la has a kind of specific crowd and a lot of ways and there's some shit
that you can do in La that literally won't fly anywhere else in the flyover.
You know,
there's,
there's certain shit that you can do here in this town like,
like it has a very certain sensibility almost all towns do.
Like Boston was famous for having a Boston sense of humor,
a lot of Boston related material that didn't work anywhere else.
So like this,
one of the best things to do is a go to as many different spots.
Do you guys find that it's very different?
The crowds he experienced the comedy store versus the road?
Yeah,
I think,
I feel like it's harder here.
The crowds are harder in la because I feel like everyone's just used to watching
entertainment all the time.
All the time and auditions and like different shows and Improv.
So people are just used to seeing other people try to,
you know,
work their craft.
Yeah.
Here when I went to Bray,
uh,
which isn't even that far,
I was like,
Whoa,
I need to get out of La Cause Bray is not that far and I get there and I'm kind
of like dry and like they just like,
it was just like this weird disconnect.
And that was a moment where I was like,
wow,
I just got to keep going other places.
Yeah.
But you know,
here's the other difference.
There's people that come to a place,
like the comedy store and they're used to seeing a lot of experimentation,
a lot of new material.
But when you're in a club like Braya,
like you got headliners coming in every week.
I mean that's really what it's like.
The Bray improv headlines coming every week.
And that's what those people say.
They go there,
they see this guy kill,
they see that God kill.
They see this girl kill.
And when you do that over and over and over again,
you,
you sees in your crowd.
Like if you look at the lineup of like the Improv and Brio,
it's just a murderer after murderer.
It's just a sterile assassins and they're all coming in for the weekends.
So like you,
you have like this whole system there where people were accustomed to a very
high level of like national level comedy.
Yeah.
I think it's easier.
This places a lot easier.
I agree.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
the thing about those places is they're not as open to experimentation though.
Yeah.
Right.
And I was hosting the weekend.
I like knew what I was doing,
but it was such a good experience.
Cause that Friday I was like,
Whoa,
La has the more educated as far as like comedy style,
like hack stuff doesn't go over in la the way we'll go over in some places like,
but that's harder to do any more anyway.
Isn't it like hacks.
Dot.
Like you really,
it's all worn out.
Yeah.
Like it doesn't exist anymore.
Right?
Like,
where's the last guy that you heard was a hack?
I just do an hack Joe's.
We see them every day.
I think.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
anybody who's on a lineup in front of me,
they mean if it's not like if they,
they,
you know,
they better be good or else I will.
I will complain about them being in front of me on a lineup no matter how long
they've been to one and no matter whatever.
You know what I mean?
It's just like if I hear a bad joke,
I just go,
why is this person have a better spot than they made in fury?
Well,
you just made it really personal.
That's not what I'm [inaudible] about.
I'll call them a hack,
you know what I mean?
And not to their face.
You run into that though.
Do you see that?
I don't see that anymore.
I really don't see hacks any,
right?
Yeah.
I remember like they used to be guys who had like a stock act,
right?
They had an act that was just interchangeable with a lot of other people's acts
and it was based on these like really common premises like okay,
here's a perfect example.
A guy going to buy tampons for his wife and he would get to the counter and the
thing wouldn't have a tag on it and they would go price check tampons,
Aisle Alto.
There was a hundred guys who did that joke and they're like,
please,
I'll pay you twice.
The money just don't do that.
Don't do that again.
How much is it?
I think it's $50 sir.
That's too much.
I saw so many people do that joke.
I mean it was one of those things where it was like,
oh my God,
this is out of control.
There was like that premise.
It was like a super common hack premise.
Yeah,
cops and donuts.
That's where that came from.
It came from hacks.
Yeah.
When I hear the words guys and girls are super different.
It listed be a totally let go.
Ironic about dating in La is hard.
Yeah.
The difference treat La and New York is
a lot of it is like,
you know,
you're just trying to think of shit to talk about.
A lot of people when it's like really based stuff,
it's a lot of the most common stuff like travel,
most common,
you know,
differences between cities.
Like all that stuff is like,
like baby blocks like building and sometimes still awesome.
Like someone doesn't take it out of the mix.
Like if you had the most awesome the difference between New York and La joke
today.
It's not like you can't talk about that subject.
Like if you,
if you have it and it's funny I'll be laughing like I'm not a comedy Snob at
all.
I think that people get silly with like,
you know what's acceptable,
what's not acceptable.
Like there's some dumb shit that's really funny.
You know like it doesn't have to all be smart like in,
it can be a stew of things like burn.
I were talking the other day about pratfalls like he has this bit and he was
trying to figure out how to,
how to like almost get like flipped on stage.
And I can't talk about it without like sort of reveal on the premise.
So he and I were like,
I was showing him like these different roles that you could do a different way.
You could fall where you're not going to get hurt,
but it'll look kind of crazy.
Your legs be over the air.
And uh,
he was like,
we were talking about like,
Prat falls like pratfalls aren't cheap.
Right.
If it's,
I'm like,
if it's,
if it's a part of a joke and it makes the joke better,
it's funny,
you know?
Yeah.
But there's some people who would back off because they worried about the
contempt of their peers,
you know,
they worry about,
oh,
what are you doing?
Flips on stage now.
Tony Hinge also
comedian,
like I like,
you know,
somebody who moves around and stuff like that.
If that's part of their natural thing,
then yeah,
they could do that.
But you know,
some people,
Joey Diaz,
one Joey moves around a lot,
but it keeps the mic and this,
I can't picture him doing Pratt off,
but he's done some,
some karate kicks on stage.
I've seen that really.
Yeah.
Joey gets crazy sometimes.
He,
but he always keeps the mic in the stand.
If you noticed that about Diaz,
he never holds the mic.
Ah.
He uses both of his hands and it keeps the mic in the stand.
He's one of the few guys that do that.
Yeah,
he's got a totally different style,
you know,
but it works,
man.
It,
he's a master of having that microphone in the stand.
Yeah.
I love what he does when he's killing.
He grabs it by its side and he looks,
it's straight up,
a few inches
down.
You just hear that the,
the,
the debate is on the monster.
He's got this new bit about Isis.
I was fucking,
tears were pouring down my eyes.
He was a red,
like a beat and screaming at the top of his lungs and the water and sweat was
flying and he's taking his jacket off while he's killing,
while he's,
Kelly used to take his jacket off to in this isis bit.
I'm like,
oh my God,
he's the best.
He's the best ever.
Yeah.
You know,
if you,
if you never seen Joey Diaz live,
you don't understand.
There's another level and he's a perfect example.
Like there's no like great intellectual truths in his act.
It's shit that he thinks is fucking funny.
He's just tried to kill,
he's trying to say the funniest shit that he could say.
Yeah.
And,
and in doing that,
like,
you know,
he hits this rare air sometimes I'll like Joey Diaz,
his hit some air that uh,
I do.
I don't think this may be like three or four other people I've ever seen hit
that level.
Like he,
there's a level of crying in the crowd during some of his bits and people just
hitting tables because they can't breathe.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause this dude is just,
and he's fucking slaying.
It's Brett's coming out of his mouth.
That's one of the fun things about the sitting in the back of a comedy room is
you get to see the shadows,
the people in front of you,
how they're physically moving different than the rest of the show.
Rest of the show.
They're pretty still,
like you might see them pop and down for laughs and stuff.
But if you're sitting in the back during a Joey Diaz said,
it's like you see like spit takes flying in the air.
One guy falling out of his seat and other guys slamming a table.
And then another thing that Joey does that I just love and I always look for is
that he kills faster than anybody else too.
Like for some reason the audience immediately can tell he's just being himself
an artist or renal.
When he walks up there and goes,
hey,
cock suckers [inaudible] bar,
and it's already happening.
Right.
They connect with them immediately.
There's none of that.
Hey,
good to meet you.
Uh,
you know,
yeah,
no,
he's,
he's just funny to look at.
Yeah,
he's funny.
Everything's funny.
His personality is funny.
He's so unique,
like,
and how he talks,
he's just everything about him.
He,
this is a unusual dude and I'm glad he's back at the comedy store too.
You know,
Joey came,
he started back a couple of weeks before I did and uh,
he told me,
he said,
man,
he goes,
it really,
really changed my act.
He said it really,
it really got me fired up.
I got excited about comedy again.
He goes,
it really like made me excited about just killing.
I just wanted to kill.
I was like,
well,
he goes,
it just gave me another shot of inspiration,
you know?
Alright.
You know,
Thompson girl and I were talking about this last night that,
um,
when you have a bunch of friends that are like really into stand up,
like everybody's like really into writing new shit,
really into performing a lot.
Like you get so energized by that.
It's like you're on this like comedy,
caffeine thing.
Yeah.
It's the way it's really like,
it's,
you know,
surround yourself with people that like you can relate to,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's why the store is so important.
That's why it's like that.
It's this weird freaky hangout spot.
You know,
like last night we were in the green room,
Zach Galifianakis,
Ken,
John,
the doctor from over movies.
Ken was there.
Yes.
I fucking guys.
Awesome.
Um,
who else was there?
Jeff Ross is back there.
Um,
and,
and tell Whitney Cummings is back there.
We're all hanging out,
having a fucking blast,
just laughing and telling Brad Williams is back there laughing and talking and
telling stories and it's just like that kind of a an environment man.
It just gets you so fired up to do comedy.
I went on that stage last night running,
you know,
I just couldn't wait to get up there.
It's like there was so much shit.
It was all in the air in that place.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's something that I forgot about man.
I really did.
I forgot about it when I left the store cause I was so angry at the
circumstances and everything.
But I think even so,
I think it got better while we were gone.
People were saying that it got better around the time of podcasting for some
reason that they sort of coincided that it was like about five years ago the
store really started picking up,
which is about when like,
uh,
this isn't that like how long Adam Carolla has been doing podcasts?
Most,
most comics about five years ago.
Yeah.
And I think that a lot of comics,
when they started doing podcasts and the Corolla showing other people's
podcasts,
people started hearing about comedy and then realizing that a lot of these
people that are comics,
they're just fucking regular people that just decided to do comedy.
Like how many people have you met in your life when you're like,
dude,
listen to me.
You should be a comedian.
No one,
never did.
I see him.
I meet people all the time.
So your cert more cynical in me.
There's some chick that was hanging out at the bar the other night.
She was whole,
various.
She was hilarious.
She was really funny.
I go,
what do you do?
You know,
she's,
which works in banking.
I go,
you should be a comedian.
You're really fucking funny.
And she's got this,
got this natural sense of delivery and personality.
I'm like,
you really should do it.
Just go to an open mic night.
Just go and watch how bad everybody sucks.
You'll want to do it cause like open mic nights are the craziest places ever it,
right.
If you want to find the epicenter of Cuckoo in Hollywood or hacks or some hacks
at open mics.
Yeah,
they're hackers.
Mostly actors.
That's a good expression.
I hate that though.
You see that a lot,
especially on killed Tony.
These guys that don't really want to be comics,
but they're doing it because they want to be come an actor.
So they kind of go through that route.
It really,
it's really noticeable.
Yeah.
Or they want to brag to their improv troupe that they went and did stand up at
the comedy store and then they tell you I'm a comic.
Yeah.
Well not only can they do,
I'm proud,
but I'm also a comedian.
Yeah.
That would be like your,
your headshot standup comedian.
Actor,
first actor slash standup comedian.
Yeah.
There's some about actors that like,
it's really difficult to get somebody to pick you for stuff.
Like it's the worst part about being an actor.
Like I know people that are actors that are like really struggling and they,
it's,
it's an insanely frustrating because it's not something you can just do.
You know?
Like,
if you do stand up,
there's an open Mike night,
you go up,
you fucking kill and you,
if you just keep doing that,
eventually somehow or another you just get better and you become a professional.
I mean that's really the,
the college of standup comedy.
But for an actor,
you've got to have somebody find you.
You've got to have somebody fine,
dude,
they've got to come get you.
They got to see you.
You do the audition,
they go,
that guy,
let's make him the guy and they take in,
they fucking put makeup on you and they push in front of the camera,
give you a bunch of shit to say and they picked you.
But guess what?
He could have done it.
They could change the gender.
She could have done it.
I mean it's like there's so many people for each role.
You know,
there's a few really good ones.
There's a few,
you know,
Marlon Brando type characters that rise through the rest.
But the reality is you've got to get picked.
And so this is weird social game that's going on.
So they're,
they're all socially like terrified.
They're afraid and not all of them,
but a lot of them,
they're afraid to truly speak their mind.
They're always like in this weird like confi they're always like hoping that you
liked them because they have the audition all the time and these powerful people
standing in front of them and go,
hmm,
I don't know.
Like Dom Irrera was telling me about an audition then he went on and how
insulting it was.
The woman's started eating her sandwich and checking her texts while he was
doing,
as long as she's eating a sandwich and checking your texts,
I was like,
Whoa,
that's dark.
Yeah.
That's rough.
And if,
if that's how you make your living and you keep going to these things and some
woman's they're eating or sandwich or some guy is a,
he's a in the middle of a text message while he's listening to you.
Thanks.
Thanks Tony.
That was very good time.
We'll be in touch and you're like,
oh my God,
I'll never eat.
You mean that's fucked.
Yeah.
And sometimes like commercial auditions,
they'll just want like a reaction and then people are like,
oh,
how was it?
They're like,
I don't know,
I just like smile,
but I don't know how I did.
Yeah,
yeah.
Commercial auditions for the worst.
When I first started,
I got sent on a lot of those and the assistant for the agent that I had was like
the worst.
He was notoriously bad at what he did because there were a few guys signed with
this agency at the store,
so he would just be hung over from a crazy night before.
And he would send you out on a bad audition,
like one that you're not even matched for,
who says we have an audition for you today at,
you know,
33 sunset boulevard at 8:00 AM.
See,
get their schedule around it.
You get excited for it.
And then you show up and it's for,
you know,
50 year old Asian woman and you're sitting there in a lobby with 50 year old
Asian women and then the guy,
it's finally your turn and the guy goes,
you know,
uh,
this isn't for you.
And I go,
but they told me to come here and be here for this.
And you go,
well I guess we could get you in here.
It's like,
I ain't never had that.
When you do that,
would you play a 50 year old Asian woman?
Well,
no,
I would just read it
so tired.
I started acting like on,
um,
when I was living in New York,
I started going on audition so it didn't do any acting,
but I got this agent and then all of a sudden they'd go,
do you want to act?
And um,
and it was really one of those like,
okay.
And then also,
and I'm going out on auditions,
zero acting experience,
none.
Right.
And I was like,
what am I doing?
Like what is this?
And it was the first time I ever got to see child stars because I didn't know
about that.
I had no idea that there was these like stage moms in the stage,
moms with their kids,
especially for like a commercial auditions.
Do you guys run into them in la?
I'd sage moms.
I've seen some,
yeah,
I have it.
I'm like,
they're the scariest,
and I grew up here,
so I saw a lot of stage moms when I was like little like in school there's like
act or kids with their stage moms and my mom was afraid of them,
so now I'm just,
I've always avoided,
but I've seen a mom out of a commercial audition who said to her,
kid,
sit down or I'm going to beat the Jesus out to you.
Like in the commercial audition,
like,
yeah,
okay.
Jesus.
Yeah,
expressions.
It's like,
Wah,
hit my kid but I'm not going to blast him the Lord.
It's the budget,
but I don't say the real Jesus.
Jesus is the fake cheese from the creator of the name.
The word licorice whips comes beejesus licorice.
It seems like the
same guy who made that word probably made up beejesus licorice whips be Jesus.
Maybe bell licorice whips.
Real licorice.
Black people.
That's hilarious.
But Jesus,
oh,
that sounds like something that Taryn,
Tina would say while promoting on the beach,
I cannot figure it out.
My computer.
I just always felt like the culture of a auditioning was always like insanely
like defeating and get felt bad.
Like,
and I used to think that like that's the reason why I think a lot of people are
depressed in Hollywood.
Like especially actors.
Like when I started going on auditions,
I f I failed miserably and all these movie auditions,
I went on it because they'll,
your agency will send you out for shit that like,
like say if they already have some movie star for a role,
they already have it cast.
They'll still take like 30 people and they'll say,
well you should,
you should go so they can see you because they might like it for something else.
And I'd be like,
what?
Like in my mind I was like,
this doesn't even make any sense.
It's like you want me to act?
So you want me to learn some lines and go and make a relationship with a casting
director.
Okay,
I get it.
I guess I get it,
but I didn't get it at all.
So I would go there and I would always feel bad after I leave.
I be like,
this is just,
I had a,
one time I went to this audition,
it was one of the most embarrassing moments ever.
I went into his audition and this lady was reading the audition and she was
asking me where I was from and I said that,
uh,
I'm from,
just moved from New York.
I said,
but,
uh,
I was,
born in New Jersey and she said,
I'm born in New Jersey too,
but I don't tell anybody that.
I tell them I'm from New York.
I go,
why?
Why wouldn't you just tell them that you're from New Jersey?
And she goes,
because,
oh,
nobody wants to be from New Jersey.
So I just tell them I'm from New York and I go,
that seems ridiculous.
She goes,
okay,
do you want to read this?
I go,
all right.
So I start reading it and she's given me these like fucking dead eyes because I
insulted her need to be from New York.
I'm mocked her.
I mean,
it was like the most,
I was like,
I was just talking to a person,
like if you said that to me and I'd be like,
ah,
yeah,
why the fuck do I lie?
Why do I tell everybody I'm from New York?
Does that make me better than if I was from New Jersey?
Like I my that ridiculous.
Instead of being proud to be from New Jersey,
so in this I have to sing to this chick,
so I have to,
I have to do these stupid lines.
Like I'm literally like,
it's like a country western song.
I'm lake side with a girl and we have like a blanket laid out and I have to sing
a Bruce Springsteen song to her and I died that day,
shine in front of her.
Like I felt my soul leaving my body as I'm like trying to soulfully sing this
Bruce Springsteen song,
this woman who's looking at me like I'm just a steaming sack of shit in her
office and then when I'm done,
she was,
thanks.
Did you try to save it at the end?
Like thank you again.
I'm Joe Rogan from New York.
No,
I know it was death.
That would be funny.
No,
it was dead,
but I had to go through with it anyway and I went through with it.
I was like,
oh my God,
a man.
Now imagine if your check and he'd go into an audition and the dude tries to
fuck you.
Right.
Or you know,
sexually harass you in some strange way.
Mr Hinchcliffe.
Yeah,
I know.
I imagine that could happen with you as well under the right circumstances with
a very aggressive gay man.
Oh it ha.
It could have happened.
It could have.
It could have,
but you what?
You'd be you I,
when I get out of the room I don't make direct eye contact with anybody.
Kept your mouth shut.
When I was auditioning
for album,
I got far along in the audition process for book of Mormon at one point,
which is like a big Broadway production.
I got in the middle of it,
kept doing good.
Got It.
Just kept moving on.
You should have seen the lobby for that.
My friend,
a bunch of little twinks trying to be Mormons or like,
you know,
musical theater.
You know what that means,
right?
Right.
Do they do that thing with the,
with the butts and the wieners?
Did you see there was an article,
I think it was like Huffington post or one of these recently about this upsurge
in Mormon porn.
Yeah.
And that there's like Mormon porn sites now to help every,
every,
everyone starts with a boy knocking on the door.
You're all like Mormon,
Mormon,
cam girls and,
and things along those lines.
And there's Mormon,
Mormon missionary,
gay sex porn bicycle
from three bang bice.
Yeah.
More than before.
And here it is.
There's,
there's no bullshit.
well,
there's a,
there's this,
I don't know if this is a,
we don't know if that's,
that's not the one that I was looking at the article.
The article was about this guy.
What does that make you?
The special effects?
These Mormons guy.
The old cheese.
Yeah.
So these,
um,
this one guy was telling you about his experience in camp,
you know,
with,
uh,
some other,
like he realized he was gay when he was gone to these Mormon camps with guys and
he was attracted to him and just took the right guy to make it happen.
And that's why he did,
you know,
he had such an exciting experience.
Now he's married with children.
He's not gay,
but wow.
So this is the story.
So he decided to make a Mormon.
You have to click.
Are you over 18,
Brian?
Click mentally.
Brian,
you have to say now,
what would you say?
Like mentally you are like,
it's 14 your maturity levels,
but 18,
18 intelligence still like Gi joes.
So yeah.
1818.
That was it.
That's what makes an eight team.
Sarah,
how old are you mentally?
Yes.
Um,
it depends.
Either I'm like 65 or 12.
Yeah,
that's a good answer.
That's it.
Like,
so when you're tired,
you're 65.
Yeah.
Or having a good time or 12 or 12 like,
yeah,
I feel like I'm like just my age mentally.
I don't know.
In the moment chick.
I'm 109 how'd that happen?
It's paid too much attention to shit,
dude here I think so.
You've taken too many variables.
I probably do.
Yeah.
Well you're a,
you're a bit obsessed.
Tony Hinchcliffe could a bit obsessed with the standup comedy
with everything today.
I thought I was dying in the shower for sure.
I was 100% positive that I was having an appendix attack.
Like something like right in my,
in my upper,
I mean lower belly and I'm just like,
this is that this is,
I can convince myself that the worst shit is happening and then what to,
yeah.
I mean I've been on the road with him and it's happened a few times.
Right.
So you're essentially a hypochondriac.
Does that what it is?
It's more of a panic attack type of thing,
but it's like not like what you think a panic.
It's just all inside the head.
Oh.
And anyway,
ended up fighting and then the appendix attack was gone that fast.
It was just one little fourth second tutor.
Rooney.
I have had that happen.
I've had that happen before.
You get a weird stomach pain,
you're like,
what the fuck is that like that's new.
Yeah.
And when it's new,
immediately my Amy,
I'm sure you guys got to be the same where it's like I've never felt that
before.
And that's gotta be something
or just farts or what were you eating all that Vegan food do?
That's a problem.
It always ends up being a fart by the way was my problems.
Broccoli shit gets impacted.
I had,
I need to put a hole in my stomach's that people can pull out the grains.
Too many grains.
I think that's essentially like diverticulitis probably in a lot of ways.
That's what happens to a,
that's what happened at Brock Lesnar.
Yeah.
It happened to a few people.
I know they had to get uh,
parts of their colon removed.
Oh yeah.
One guy know,
caught it before it got too bad,
but you just get impacted.
And uh,
Anthony Bordain was telling me that it can be anything he said he could like be
like a pumpkin seed or something gets stuck in there.
Like he eats something,
gets stuck and then it creates an abscess.
Is like,
it's not just meet like with Brock Lesnar,
supposedly it was just,
he all he ate was meat.
Like it wasn't eating any fiber and his bowels get all fucked up because of it.
Yeah.
Whoa,
wow.
Yeah.
You got to eat.
Like you have to eat healthy,
you know,
like fiber's important for your body.
It's not,
it's not just a luxury,
it's a necessity.
Like if you want this thing to work right,
you gotta eat lettuce,
it's got a push everything out.
Yeah.
And when you don't,
it can really,
and then there's some people that get it to just have a propensity for it
apparently.
But when they,
when they have to remove like sections of your intestines and Shit,
Oh God,
clean my bedroom the other day and I have a pretty big bed.
But underneath bed
it's like in the middle,
you never can get anything on,
you know,
like if something falls under the bed.
So I was trying to get everything and I pulled out a single cheeseburger from
Mcdonald's that I guess I was eating and I threw,
I threw it on the ground or something.
And it just went in there and get like to you,
I know budget,
how can you live?
Like I haven't had mcdonalds in my bed for at least six months and so that,
but when I opened it,
it looked brand new.
It looked just exactly the same.
You would buy that perfect apartments like the raft of a survivor stranded at
sea.
It's just scattered disarray with bobbers and nets and one shoe
pirate in the corner for some reason.
Yeah,
that big area in the middle we can't reach under your bed area is a problem.
It's disgusting it.
Cause if you ever do move,
you bed your bed,
you're like looking at it going,
that's so gross.
How much would I have to pay you to lick that?
The center area we can't reach.
Just do the whole line.
All the line up from the head to the keep your tongue down on the ground from
the foot of the bed to the head of the bed.
Like an Imac.
It would only take an imac to get you to do that.
Hell yeah.
Wow.
What about Ipad mini?
I licked,
I licked the stripper pole.
I licked the stripper pole at a crazy girl as a couple of months ago on stage.
We were doing comedy there.
Uh,
and I just said some hot girl just got off and I was like,
damn,
that girl is hot.
And I just like licked it as a joke.
Everyone was like,
but then I thought about it and then I had like a canker on my time for like
three days.
Yeah.
Welcome to the wonderful world of new age canker.
I was freaked out for a couple of days but it was so hilarious.
That is so hilarious.
David Arquette owns that place now and I told him like he would,
he did kill Tony and I told him about that and you just give me a high five.
He's like that's great.
That's hilarious.
He owns a strip club.
And what a good mood for a fucking celebrity that's just getting divorced.
What an excellent move.
And that place is a,
they do comedy occasionally there.
Yeah they do shows art like music sometimes.
And she calmed me that it's totally not set up for comedy though.
Cause they have like a strobe light facing the comic.
So you're onstage and you're just having elliptic Caesar's and you can't see
anything.
Whatever that is.
It click elliptical seizures,
epileptic.
He Fuck [inaudible] lip ellipses.
That sounds uh,
that sounds terrible.
Yeah.
And uh,
it's,
it's a,
the ceiling cuts down so it's like chops the top part of your head off so they
can't even see you.
Oh,
part of your head.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
We'll just do your comedy on your knees.
Lifted you comedy like as a like to like a dancer's routine.
Do your comedy,
like don't even like talk about the fact that got your leg wrapped around the
pole when you're going around in circles,
talking about your day
doing stupid style.
There's a lot of those cool little spots in Hollywood though that aren't what
you think they are.
You know,
it looks like it would be like,
it's like kind of a hangout.
Aren't you doing a the spot tonight or the
Watkins?
Yeah,
that's a little,
where's it at?
What's it called?
Three of three o'clock.
A cool little realm.
It really,
really is.
I,
it's a,
it's just like this,
it's like a cool hip bar.
Um,
and then you go through these double doors and it's a cool showroom.
One of my favorite little show rooms and all of Hollywood.
Nice.
Yeah,
it's really neat.
Yeah.
And he's doing one of those like Thunderpussy style shows that people yell out
topics and you discussed them.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Yeah.
Should be fun.
Well,
fund your post.
He's a really fun show to do it too.
And if you have the right crowd and it's right.
Exactly.
And this show,
because it's in Hollywood,
so the audience is a little more open than a Pasadena crowd who's a little bit
more outside.
So the crowds are always a little bit better for this than for,
you know,
the passenger,
I mean,
not good.
They're not necessarily a better crowd.
There were more interactive crowd to give you the topics that you need,
like a better,
like a better group of suggestion.
Right,
exactly.
A little bit wide open with suggestions.
Yeah.
You can't get a better crowd than the ice house.
Literally don't think it's possible.
Exactly.
What only was possible.
They're so good and like everybody,
they're so nice too.
It's just like the whole like storm of coolness there last night.
It was so much fucking fun,
man.
Yeah.
That's a great audience.
It was pretty powerful.
That was amazing last night.
Yeah.
Good God.
Damn time Tommy should grow.
It was killing me.
Oh my God.
He's funny.
Thompson Gora is a god damn monster right now.
He's just getting funnier all the time.
Just all the time.
It's constantly working at it.
Ian Edwards to slayed it.
Slided last night.
Have you seen bill burns and new special now go get it.
Really?
It's amazing.
It's really good.
It's really fun.
It's like like actual bill bar,
like doing a set.
It doesn't seem like you're doing a special at all.
I like sometimes you've seen people do specials and they look like a little more
tense than they do when they're,
you know,
they're just doing a set burden.
Nailed it.
It's totally him.
It's awesome.
It's like black and white,
right?
Yeah.
I just wanted to do a black and white.
He said he's decided that like everything's to HD.
It's like everything's like,
you know,
so much focus on high resolution and looking at things like he just decided to
go old school to a black and white.
The jokes.
How long before you guys decide to put something out?
I want to make sure it's really,
really good before I do,
I'm still so new.
Right?
Yeah.
I'm just scared to do anything too early.
Everyone keeps telling me to take my time.
Do you have a timeline?
I want to not be working a day job within the next year.
To him that's ambitious.
So like two years in a comedy.
No Day job.
Maybe two and a half years.
That's ambitious as fuck.
Yeah.
I want it to,
I mean,
just doing enough to just like survive.
Obviously not being like touring and,
right.
Right,
Just like not working a day job.
Yeah.
And stuff like that.
It's hard.
How long before you quit your job?
MMM,
I was,
well,
I got a job working at the comedy store,
so I went solo just with that.
Yeah,
for,
yeah,
for
four years.
Just made enough money to get by working there.
He at just just barely enough money to get by because back then wasn't the same
exact regime of managers.
Right.
And what was happening before where they were notorious for um,
for shaving hours that you'd actually work.
And back then there were also was literally one fifth as many employees as there
is now.
So I was one of like five guys that was working phones during the day and then
working the door at night.
So I was struggling.
Wow.
I wasn't even getting what I was working.
Those stories are so cool though.
When someone goes from being a doorman,
like Ari goes from being a doorman at the comedy store doing his comedy central
special at the comedy store.
[inaudible] you know,
and then the name of it he liked,
he made it paid regular.
That was the name.
Cause like that was always the thing.
Like he wanted to become a paid regular.
Do you worked at it for like four and a half years before she finally got him in
[inaudible]
but it's,
that's such a great story.
Like going from a guy just with an idea in his head who started doing open mics
and from there become a professional comedian.
I mean working the door,
worked in the cover booth,
doing all that shit,
answering phones,
doing all the shit the comics do.
Like that's one of the few places in the country where comics go from just being
employees of the club to like national headliners.
Yeah.
Same thing with rand is easy.
Yes.
It was just finishing up when I was arriving.
Like he wasn't working there anymore.
But you heard that he would talk about working there?
Yes.
Like I met him,
he worked there and now I know as a TV star.
Yeah.
I would come by to do sets.
I think when I was on news radio or maybe it might've been fear factor.
I don't know which one it was when I first met him.
Hold on.
When Brenda's easy start.
I'm not sure.
Oh,
I know exactly when.
Actually,
it was November of 2011 because he was in,
he was in one of the towers when the plane set on September 11th and he's like,
fuck it.
Well,
no,
no.
That's not what he started doing comedy right after that?
No,
because he was in the Carlos Mencia video and that was 2007 I think you mean
2001 is when timber 11 to Hollywood.
September 11 2001 yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
You said 2011 oh,
okay.
Yeah.
You said that timber 11 yeah.
Gotcha.
I know,
I forget.
It's hard to believe at nine 11 was 13 almost 14 years.
Wow.
That's weird.
Right?
That's crazy.
Do you think time is moving faster?
Yes.
Oh my God.
Perfect dancer.
That was probing stoner talk.
Oh my God,
yes.
Followed by a long run on sentence where I throw in a bunch of likes,
so like I was like,
maybe like time is like different
me.
I was freaking out about the Berenstain bears,
the spelling of the last name.
Yeah,
it's different.
It's different and it wasn't always like that.
It's always been like that
and it's stain.
Wait,
wait,
what is it?
What do they call it in the Matrix?
In the matrix
spelled like stain
stain,
but I swear it was Berenstein I've been cost.
Most people don't know what the fuck
we're talking about.
A series of children's children's books.
I said barren Steen and someone corrected me and then I looked at it and I was
like,
oh yeah,
Ooh.
Like why did I think it said steam?
It was like I didn't continue the sentence.
I got to Barron's and there's an end of the end.
I'm like steam.
It must be seen.
Like I didn't,
I didn't even like attempt to read it.
Like I realize like sometimes words are so similar to other words that you don't
really read them.
You kind of know,
oh I know what that is,
but you don't go and you just,
oh,
Barron's dean,
you know Wolfowitz if you saw like Wolfowitz but like one of the letters was
different,
you'd still probably say Wolfowitz cause you put it in.
I go and I've seen that before and he just looked to save time.
You know,
you,
you say it.
So for all of us that thought,
I mean it was just one of those things like you never really read the word.
Did you pull it up
Congress if though right?
Isn't that what we did?
We talk about this curse too much.
It's just show these,
well I bet show that ease people at home.
What the fuck we're talking about.
I thought it was a neat too,
so I bet it's one of those curse a phase that looks like and
I don't think it is man.
I think it's just the way it's a straight up stain.
Something happens.
Something happens,
seriously convinced for so long.
I went like three days just like looking like a crazy person.
Bernstein bears.
No,
it doesn't.
It looks like that a should be an e.
But I think it's one of those things you just sort of chunk those words together
that lettered the,
all those letters in your memory.
I remember that there was a ais.
I think that,
uh,
I think it's one of those things you don't,
you just don't read it.
If everyone was already
fuck,
name his last name.
I don't know.
So stupid in this Dane.
You good say what's wrong with Barrett's thing?
That's silly.
Bernstein is just as ridiculous.
Well,
I thought it was Berenstain the whole time.
It must be one of those tracks where it was like you see two e's before and then
you think the third one's gotta be an easier thing.
It's like pop and soda.
I think that just where you're like your mom,
your parents where it's like,
yeah.
Marin's stain.
Oh well that would make sense.
Berenstein Berenstain and you'd say dean.
Yeah.
What'd I say?
Getting to be more and more.
He'll bill t e I n it strictly,
what's the name of those Jew?
Bayer's
Barron.
Yeah.
It's like you ever wonder like why certain languages came up with certain,
sounds like some languages have beautiful flowing melodic sounds to them.
Like they have like a rhythm to them.
Like if you ever heard someone speaking Portuguese,
like the Brazilians that speaks Portuguese,
it's such a cool sound language,
Blah bishop.
Whether they have this like sort of like almost like they're dancing like this
flow to it and then you'll hear like,
like some like really harsh German [inaudible] Bush didn't like really like,
yeah,
it's like this weird sort of like guttural and then like you know some of the
Sephardic languages and it's,
yeah,
it's some crazy ass noises.
You know Canadians a,
Oh that's about as normal as you get.
Add a little a to some words about it.
They're just a little far up north.
They're all too,
don't be picking out Canadian.
The bear chosen people as far as I'm concerned.
The Berenstain bears had this one book called new neighbors and I always thought
it seemed racist because it was like Asian panda bears that moved in and look
how angry the dad is.
He's like Asians moving in next door and bears,
oh that's hilarious.
They went with pandas madness
looking good damn weirdos building in moves it build their Chinese restaurant
where neighbors
who have an oriental rug,
it's hilarious.
They're even wearing kind of like colorful,
festive Chinese colors.
Those are definitely Chinese outfits.
Like look at how it's cut.
And it's like the shirts go all the way up to the chin.
Fucking panda bears all wearing the same.
If somebody tried to release that today,
like salon.com would be all over it.
Yeah.
Subtle racism and children's stories.
Why it's wrong.
Yeah.
Finding racist.
But I think that is exactly what that was.
I mean,
that's not clever.
They're not hiding that panda.
But why isn't it black pairs?
You guys are Brown.
Have some black bears move in.
No.
Too Edgy
against black people.
Exactly.
So they had to go with pandas.
Is Asians fucking,
they keep their eye on their business and they fucking keep moving forward.
They don't riot.
Asian people don't close off the fucking four oh five they're nice and they get
things done.
Okay.
They don't get caught up in bullshit.
But if you,
if you use black bears,
boy,
dark skin,
light skin did bears versus dark skin.
But polar bears come in and fuck up everything.
They've chose.
Black and white ethnically ambiguous
skin.
Yes.
That's crazy.
Their hair.
It's clear.
It's not actually white.
Yeah.
See if he could pull up a picture of polar bear skin.
Polar bear hair.
Clear polar bear hair clear.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It's like a,
almost like,
you know those fibers that they use those light fibers.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The fiber optics,
like that kind of shit.
I mean that's what it looks like almost.
It's like a,
a natural white,
but it's like a natural clear rather.
But altogether they look white.
Well,
is there a bald,
is there a picture of like a bald skin,
but see if you could pull up a polar bear.
Heres a ball.
Polar bear.
I don't think they don't live.
Like some bears get mange and they survive,
but polar bears live exclusively in polar habitat.
That's what their hair looks like.
That's not a good picture.
But you get a sense of it.
It's,
it's more clear that it does look pretty white,
but apparently it's clear like technically,
so there's just a complete absence of color.
So then they take all those together and they look white when they're on the
animal.
Yeah,
I mean it is white.
Obviously it's white,
but they think they consider it clear,
so our brain reads it as white Berenstain bears these days.
Awful to grow up with
these racist parents writing these polar bear bucks.
Imagine what kind of Shit life you must've led to come back as a polar bear.
What a Dick.
Can you say that you say that you don't want to live up there?
It sounds like a lonely world.
You can always come back as like a magnet
that would suck worse.
Someone has the glass half full.
Yeah,
but being a polar bear would be especially sucky.
Yeah.
Freezing cold,
jumping in the water all the time.
All you're eating is like seals,
shit and drinking coca cola.
What would you do for a Klondike Bar?
I think you could be fun.
There could be some positives like name them,
like sliding around on the ice.
You can do that.
You can do that and you're a person throwing up bear party.
They'd get more hurt as a person.
You would get more hurt sliding around.
You'd be less durable.
Yeah,
like just the thought of sliding around on my polar bear belly.
That would be super fun.
Oh,
you ever did the,
uh,
the slip and slide?
Oh yeah.
Done it.
Yeah.
Well,
I haven't done it in quite some time,
but yes,
I've done it.
It's a child's game actually.
Get everyone's done it right.
It has never been done.
Slipping side.
That's not something you like trying to shock them with your knowledge thing
that I did when I was young.
There's an adult one that they are,
they're trying to actually put a,
it's called slide the city.
Uh,
and there actually where you,
it's adult slipped inside throughout the whole entire city of Los Angeles.
They got a water slide in Brazil where you go like 55 miles an hour.
That's awesome.
The fastest water slide.
See if you could pull up the fastest waterslide Brazil.
That's a giant slip and slide.
That's hilarious.
The whole city of Los Angeles.
So you slide through the whole city and one push.
No,
I think it's the water moves you a little,
but oh,
and we all can't shower for a week.
You gotta be careful about waterparks.
I know a chick whose daughter got sick from a waterpark and she want to be in
partially paralyzed.
She had some sort of infection getting into her ear and it became like
meningitis or something like that.
Waterparks can get nasty man.
All these little kids are shit in that water and all these weird people are
traveling around in their diseases.
It's just a breeding ground for bacteria.
That's why when you go to a lot of them,
they just reek of chemicals to just pour in fucking coring and that water to
kill everything and you get in and you're like,
Whoa,
like I'm bathing in chemicals here.
This doesn't even feel like water.
You know?
And it's kind of warm too.
There's a bunch of people in the water and warm water and everyone's just pissed
and
can see like the sunblock splotches.
They should do like they should take like a scoop and bring it to a lab and find
out exactly how much of that water is pissed and shit.
It's like a measurable amount.
I'll admit I do it
get the worse.
They just have this thing at the admit you do it.
Yeah.
If I'm in in that like a waterpark.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
It's like when in Rome.
I mean it feels good for the p around.
It's warm.
You're trying to be silly or do you really pay when you go to a waterpark?
Yeah,
I think he does.
I don't even think he's in the pool when he does it.
I think he's standing outside of the pool and do it.
He's the guy which is pissing his pants.
Jumps in the water,
wait till a kid swim spa.
Wait,
Kid Swims by and you pee on kids.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
it's like blowing a fighter on a kid.
That's hilarious.
Have you ever heard her on a kid?
There's a big difference being blown apart on a kid and pissing on him.
Okay.
And your parents,
kids.
Parents might be upset if you fart on their kid,
they'll beat your ass if you're peeing on him,
but they can never tell.
It's the only Legal Way to pee on a kid.
What do you mean they can never tell them?
They will never know if I pee on the kid.
Is it illegal?
Appear on here.
It definitely is a legal to PR on a kid unless you're in a Kelly doesn't seem to
think it is.
Well,
he was his,
it wasn't just being charged with peeing on the girls being charged with having
sex with an underage girl I guess.
Right?
Yeah.
I think it would have been okay at even at a water park that according to Brian,
she called it pee pee.
Totally count.
So she didn't say Piss your honor.
Motion to dismiss.
The girl said Pp.
Mr. Kelly said Piss.
So clearly we're talking about two different things.
One of them is
more cultural significance attached to it.
This is a strange time for race relations,
isn't it?
If you noticed,
this is a very tense time in America for race relations,
black storm trooper to equal at all out though is they're going to help.
I don't know,
but there are bad guys,
stormtroopers or bad guy.
I think he's a good guy that is playing a bad guy for a second.
Then preview that we saw stole a costume and he's like,
Oh,
don't say this.
Spoiler alert.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
No one,
no one knows that.
That's just a guess.
Oh,
okay.
You're back.
All right.
I thought you were giving up the secret nerd info.
Have you been following this Sony leak of all the crazy stuff that's been coming
out from the hackers that have hacked Sony.
So a bunch of hackers have hacked Sony and they like locked stony office is
down.
They stole movies that haven't been released and I've been torrenting them.
They're releasing their private emails of like how much like like does it,
there's this one real,
real well known producer.
They're just trashing Angelina Jolie's.
Like I don't care about this bid sheet,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah Blah.
And they're releasing all this.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
like all this budget info.
Like,
like there's the new Seth Rogen movie that's a with James Franco and it's
showing how much more he gets paid.
Then James Franco,
Seth Rogan,
and it's just dirty shit.
And they're just,
it's just like all the other like leaks.
They've been slowly leaking it.
And releasing new stuff that's just fucked up now.
What do you think they're trying to do there?
When you're there,
you think they're trying to shut down Sony.
Do you think they're trying to just have fun?
I uh,
I don't know that cause they don't really know for sure who's doing it.
At first they thought it was North Korea because of that.
Oh,
that's right.
Cause that new movie,
I honestly think it's just angry Asians that uh,
because of that movie,
they have no connection with North Korea.
But God,
you're here to give your doctor Brian fucking work done whatsoever.
I to the,
and I'm just saying when I say stuff like that,
it's like if I had to guess,
but doesn't the,
the North Korea thing makes sense,
right?
I mean,
especially if they're released it and change Franco and Seth Rogen information
when they were on that movie together,
that was about assassinating the president of North Korea.
Right,
right.
You know,
they have hackers working for them.
They must.
Yeah.
But there was a whole article about it,
which they're not really good at much there.
Like they build,
they build rockets that just like fall over when they hit,
you know,
launch your taunting them.
They,
they're now listening to Tame Creek.
Isn't that the one place where they don't listen?
You say that about how the fuck did they find out about this James Franco,
obviously they're paying attention.
No,
they were pissed at that was being released,
right?
Yeah.
I would have said no to that movie.
I would have said,
ah,
you know,
they kill people for real over there.
Like this shit is in a movie.
Like
that fucking guy is essentially like one of the last real old school dictators
on the planet who runs an empire and you ask people under his iron fist,
I mean he's running that country and his dad was running that country.
He just got it from his dad.
I mean that you don't want to fuck with that.
Right the way you want.
If you want to fuck with that.
Only with like peace talks or a war.
Like those are the only two.
Like you don't want to like mock them.
Yeah.
Do you James Franco?
It's fine.
It's James Franco.
James Franco.
I know that's how we think.
If they showed up at Jane Franco's house,
fucking cut his throat and hung him by his ankles and you know out the second
story window and you'd be like,
oh,
okay,
those are,
these are people like it doesn't,
they don't give a fuck if you are an actor.
Like they don't care.
They don't care if you're famous.
They're famous too,
you know?
But they're famous for that.
The kid is famous for like killing his uncle.
He killed like his uncle and his uncle's family and his children and then gave
his wife a promotion,
like killed their kids and gave the wife a promotion.
Like she's done like some gangster shit man.
It sounds like a game of Thrones episode duty actually do in North Korea.
What did that say?
What did you say?
It's getting really dirty.
The lashes out at Sony,
exact four horse snipe.
I protect my
brand.
It's getting really dirty because like,
I mean everyone that's Sony has worked with like there's information going out
so it's getting like actors are now fighting back and Sony's having to release
all these like,
apologies.
I mean it's getting every email.
Oh they said nasty shit.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean,
cause it's,
imagine you know the how managers are in Hollywood or you know,
just Hollywood people,
how they talk back and forth.
You know,
we could buy that person,
fuck this person,
they suck and all that shit.
Did someone call Kevin Hart a whore or is that what happened?
Who called Kevin Hart a whore.
The biggest in an email.
Yeah.
And
I protect my brand that guys,
he's smart.
That's what he is stupid.
Just making money.
Kevin Hart is smart as fuck.
He's working hard.
Yeah.
Plus he's like Super Nice.
You know,
how do you call that guy a whore?
Yeah,
I saw him,
uh,
organically battle Tony Rock and in big the urban show that they have at the
comedy store,
the big trip and on Tuesdays or whatever,
just organically
started,
sold out main room and they were laying into each other one night.
I remember being with a bunch of Comedians,
like one of those ones where you're holding on to shit,
you know,
they're the best at it.
And Kevin Hart vs Tony Rock and Kevin Hart genius that he is just waited and
kept sitting on the fact that Tony Rock is Chris Rock's brother.
Every time Tony would throw something good at,
um,
you know,
you're only famous because of this and that,
whatever.
And like,
and Kevin just kept waiting so that by the time,
10 jokes in when he said,
you're just a bung gas brother,
you know what I mean?
Or whatever the place just,
it was over because he waited so long for it.
Everybody thought it was going to be each one and he'd get them on another one.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Those rows battles can be brutal,
man.
Yeah.
Jen Murphy and her ex boyfriend.
Oh,
that was great.
Oh good Lord.
She eviscerated that poor character.
Yeah,
it was fun.
Those,
those a roast battles are fun because you know one of the things about it is
that it's like a writer's show.
It's like it's a joke writing affair.
That's what it's all about.
So I'll just about writing jokes clowning each other.
I love that he makes them hug it out at the end of it too.
Yeah.
Every,
everyone ends in a hug.
There was one time it didn't and then into [inaudible] the person who won didn't
want to hug the other person,
but the whole room turns on you quick.
Even though he had just won,
he didn't want a hug,
so he goes,
man,
fuck this.
And started walking in.
The whole crowd went from clapping too with the guy.
Like he lost respect immediately and had to really like the rest of the night he
was working on fixing his reputation with everyone.
Why they clean it up quick by not respecting the role,
the house,
the role,
ghetto fast ferry space.
That's a shirt.
That's a white guy.
We don't know for sure.
That should be a band.
Very good.
Oh,
fast.
Sounds like a good band.
Name.
One of the very ghetto fast concert.
Very ghetto.
Fast as in town.
Dude.
I hear they're on some new math.
Vgf Baby.
I could start a band right now.
Let's do it.
Four of us.
Very ghetto.
Fast.
Yeah.
We can't say what the CIC sang UNL dance right quick.
Come on,
y'all just shake beads in her hair.
Vgf back again.
Did you ever go to the comedy festivals?
Have you ever been to Montreal or any of those festivals?
I've never been there.
Montreal.
I have done a couple like one night things.
I was with you.
Toronto,
Toronto just for laughs one nighter and I did one with Jeff Ross and Chicago,
um,
a couple of years ago
and yeah,
no,
I done the Travers city comedy festival,
which was awesome.
Great Festival.
Jeff Garlin and Michael Moore,
the filmmaker,
a run a comedy festival each year in traverse city,
which is like Trevor City.
It's like northern Michigan.
It's like the cherry capital.
It's,
Oh shit.
Unbelievable.
It's a winter fest basically,
and they shut down this whole strip of this amazing,
like it looks like,
like wonder some winter wonderland city and they have Ferris wheels and all this
big sledding hills and all this winter stuff.
Everybody dresses all warm and I've never heard of this.
It's awesome.
That's incredible.
That's awesome.
And they do this every year in the winter.
But what time in the winter?
Uh,
I'm not sure.
Who would you do it with?
I did it with,
uh,
Kirk Fox matted girth.
Stephanie,
some Bari Garland.
Sinbad,
Dave Foley.
Yeah.
How was day four was doing?
Stand up.
How is it?
Well,
I did an improvised show with him where?
Wait,
what was the thing?
Oh yeah,
it was the setlist show where you don't,
you don't know what you're going to do until you look or look behind you.
And this was in a theater,
right?
And a word pops up and you have to pretend like you have a bit about that.
You just roll with it.
He ended up taking his pants down.
It was epic theater exploded because they're not,
you want to talk about going on the road and you know what you can do and
pushing the lines.
Well,
they were really weren't expecting that in good old winter land.
Come on,
let me make you Cherry Pie.
Welcome to Travers city.
Like that's that Seti.
Dave Foley just goes,
what?
Powell and I remember we were downstairs,
the green rooms in a basement.
You just heard this roar and there was a TV but it was muted and we're all
sitting in the green room and you hear this bra and we're like,
what the hell?
And you look and Dave Foley's pants where?
At his ankles on this TV in the green room.
And we're just like,
Holy Shit.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Fully is a killer joke writer man.
Oh yeah,
he,
I was crushed.
I was really happy when he decided to do some stand up because it was one of
those things.
It's the same kind of a thing where even though he's a,
an established actor and a established hilarious guy from kids in the hall,
there's still,
he couldn't always get work.
You know,
he's having a hard time getting gigs and you,
you know,
you have to get picked to do gigs.
It's just the way it is.
You get cast,
you know,
or you do your own thing.
You create your own thing or you get cast and then the ultimate create your own
thing.
You stand up.
So he just started doing stand up,
you know,
I just want to see it.
I haven't seen a standup.
I would imagine it'd be very funny.
Yeah.
He's just such a smart dude.
He's one of the smartest people I know.
He's such a fascinating character.
Or would amaze me.
What really ended up stealing that festival for me was,
you know,
Sinbad did a show and I was thinking of myself,
I,
you know what?
I'm going to go do this other show I'm going to through right after this spot.
I'm gonna go do this because it's at the festivals.
There's always multiple spots you could do.
But I had a chance to sit in the back of the theater and watch Sinbad for a few
minutes and I was amazed.
Everything that I heard about him went out the window.
When I saw Sinbad live,
I was honestly shocked at what he was doing.
I was shocked because I was for sure thinking I was going to watch every single
thing that I've been told about him is that he's a hack.
He's this,
he's that Bobby by sucks,
he's washed up and next thing you know I'm sitting in the back of this theater,
just slow clapping like that.
I swear.
Premises delivery,
like what was so special about it?
He would go in and out of stuff.
He was just crush,
crush and then he would go,
what's next?
And he would just wait for somebody in the crowd to say anything and he would
literally,
basically he was thunder plussing it.
He was staying stand up on the spotting it,
but he has 35 years of bank and confidence and energy and I don't think he's
always been that way.
Like I remember how goofy is specials looked when I was kid when I was a kid.
I don't really remember anything that he talked about really is and that's all I
can remember.
Go Ham,
I go,
hey,
I'm a go.
But he was on fire man.
Not the type of stuff that I was expecting at all.
Like what kind of premises do we use?
Surprise by luck.
His points or really?
Yeah.
When,
how long ago was this?
This was a about a year ago.
You don't hear about them that much anymore?
That's where we had him on killed Tony a couple months ago.
Him and Jeff Garlin on the same episode and that was a blast and we got to see
some of it there too.
He's great at riffing then.
No Shit.
Just super nice.
She tried to say you're in black guys.
Just Sinbad,
32 dark posts.
Only his pants though.
Those hammer pants.
If you could bring those back,
there'll be a strong move cause someone has to be the first person to slap those
pants on in the first place.
We're wearing them and silver lake MC hammer pants,
ironically,
and they are garland and Sinbad.
Samsung Hammer.
I did send that.
I've never met the gentleman.
He was really,
really nice.
You'd be really surprised.
I bet he's a nice guy.
Is Never,
never heard a bad thing about him.
Never heard he's a duck.
This episode with Garland and Sinbad,
I think it's like 35 and 32 years or something crazy that they've both been
doing.
Standups are the comedians.
I think there was one or two that had their first time ever on stage.
We're getting immediate feedback from over 60 years of comedy experience.
70 if you throw in me and Brian,
but that's crazy.
Yeah,
towels.
Oh yeah,
that's,
that's another funny thing that I'll tell you the only,
the only thing on his rider,
I swear to God,
I got to the,
I got the,
in the green room,
there's a little cabinet things sitting there and it just had 10 hand towels on
it.
And there was a note that said for Sinbad and the assistant that brought me
down,
I go,
what's that?
And she goes,
that's the only thing on his rider 10 clean hand towels.
So hilarious.
Black dudes love towels.
It's true of to pat the forehead down.
You know,
Bill Byrd did that and his latest special I was gonna I was gonna call him up
and ask him it.
He
had his forehead down with a towel yet sitting there and the other thing was
kind of,
he had a glass of water.
It was just a glass,
not a bottle of water with a cap and actual class.
Like he's,
he's so old school.
He had a glass of water on stage.
Like you could totally see him doing that too.
Yeah,
it probably was tap water,
Eh,
I'll just take it out of the phone.
These guys now everybody's got a bottle of water.
Have fucking bottled water.
I think there's this,
I think it's a fucking scam.
That's what I think.
I think they just take that shit out and they s they sell it to you and they
look at you like you're a fucking idiot when you pay for it.
Every time with the cap,
what I'm doing,
what am I,
why?
Why am I putting in time on this job?
He's got one of those voices,
man.
You know,
he's a guy that has also benefited tremendously from podcasts because he goes on
these rifts every week.
He does his podcast completely by himself,
which I've done before,
which is fucking hard,
man.
It's really hard.
It's hard not to a slide into a being boring,
you know?
Right.
The monotonous,
it's hard to be entertaining,
but he's,
he's fucking entertaining doing it.
And there's something to be said for not having video too.
There's something to be said for video,
but there's also something to be said for just audio.
Just audio is a type of entertainment,
like,
like putting it down on youtube,
putting a podcast on Vimeo and all that stuff.
It's all great.
Nothing,
nothing bad about it.
But occasionally I just like listening to shit and burst podcasts the best for
that because it's just him.
You could tell it's just him with a couple pieces of paper at his desk and he
just ran.
You know,
it's interesting listening to kill Tony versus watching killed Tony because I
usually always watch it,
but lately I've been listening to it and you don't judge who's on stage as much
when you,
you're just listening to this open miker talk.
Sometimes it's actually way better to listen to the audio because you're
actually hearing what he's trying to say like almost as a character instead of
seeing the video part.
It's,
it's neat how some podcasts changed.
Well even comedy,
I think comedy,
I love watching it but I also love just lying back like with some headsets on
closing my eyes,
listening to a set.
I like doing that too.
You know,
I like,
you know,
like when I was a kid we used to listen to albums.
Like that was a big thing.
Like comedy albums,
like Cheech and Chong and you know,
listen to old bill Cosby albums and when we would sit and listen to them,
I would just be like,
you'd just be sitting around listening to the words,
just looking off in the room you were in,
you know,
you,
it's,
there's something about that,
the allowing your mind to like go on a little dance and not getting any visual
stimuli.
You're just sort of it and putting it all together in your mind.
Some about that.
That's really fucking cool.
It's,
it's not,
I w I would definitely like if someone had to choose between never seeing people
again or always seeing people again,
I would always go with always seeing people again.
But there's something cool about just comedy cds.
Yeah.
It's Kinda like when you read a
book and you're,
and you're thinking about something else and you're like,
oh I have to go back to the beginning when you watch video and audio cause
you're focusing,
I'm like,
oh that guy's hair's weird.
Or Why is he wearing that?
Instead of like you listen to the judge,
she like,
oh,
he's actually funny.
If I was just listening and not looking at his outfit and how weird he is,
whatever,
whatever it is.
But then there's people that you know like Joey will you want to see him?
Exactly.
When do you think you to say?
Yeah,
I just want to say I think it's kind of cool for us because I mean sometimes
people don't know what we look like.
They're just like,
oh,
you're pretty.
And they like,
Tony should have your own show.
I'm a producer.
Producer,
Huh?
Yeah.
Do you guys get Weirdos fall on you because of the show?
Oh,
oh my God.
The weirdest people.
I someone made a sub reddit.
Brian sent it to me.
Sub reddit just for me,
except they,
he took,
I mean,
it's like flattering.
It's slash creepy mean and they took my Instagram pictures and it's like a
whole,
just like just my pictures and just like one word,
titles like sunbathing or legs,
like whatever it,
my picture is,
they're just,
it's the description of categorize them all.
Oh yeah.
Oof.
It's very creepy.
How many dudes do you think if you had it like a round about number of,
of spanked it to pictures while these two in this room?
I mean,
Tony's done it together.
I'm looking at the phone.
Me and Tony,
you're lucky.
Strong.
That whole sentence together.
That's it.
That's the nickname he has for me.
Tony.
Tony's do that all the time.
That's probably who made the subreddit by the way.
Oh God.
He definitely spanked it to my,
uh,
both of our picture is how long do you girls think
you'll keep doing this and do you think,
do you like,
do you have a plan?
Do you,
do,
do you have like a,
like a transition to becoming a professional standup plan?
I said what you guys would love to do.
You want to do your own podcast?
Um,
yeah,
I've thought about doing my own podcast for sure.
We've talked about it.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know.
I think that the benefit of killed Tony,
there's still so much benefit for us because there's so much that we,
I feel like I've learned in like a small amount of time.
Just from being like holding yourself to a standard of writing in this stuff all
the time and meeting people and getting feedback from people who've been doing
it longer.
That's,
you can't ask for that.
You can't find that.
Right.
It's true.
And you guys ever have a material cross?
What are each other's?
Yeah,
like current event type shit.
Oh you're writing a new minute every week.
Her and I are totally different.
Yeah.
Completely different.
The comedians like,
yeah,
two completely different styles,
different voices.
Kevin talks a little bit more about topical stuff and her family and Sarah
organically
just ends up talking about like the most random small thing you can imagine.
You know how like there's like some subjects when you go to an open mic night or
any sort of a show where guys are working on new material.
Like,
um,
remember that one Brian,
when the Chinese uh,
pilot crashed into the American pilot and his name was one way and that became
like the most ridiculously overused joke in the history of comedy.
Like everybody had a joke about this guy named Wong way who's a Chinese fighter
pilot.
Everyone has a Tinder joke.
Everyone has a cosmic joke.
Right?
Yeah.
Cosby's another perfect example.
Like if you go on an open Mike night today,
most likely five or six people before you have already told Cosby jokes.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well like it's kind of like you said earlier.
Um,
I feel like I only,
I,
there's things that people talk about all the time and I know it's going to be
what everyone's saying at an open mic.
But if I feel like I have a better joke about it than everybody else and I'll
absolutely do it,
I don't care if everyone else talking about it because if it's better than
everyone else's,
it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Good for you.
You don't have to,
just because the subjects are have been,
you can,
especially if you're just working on jokes,
which is essentially what you're doing.
You're doing sets of new shit every week.
You're,
you're like in a constant state of working on jokes.
Yeah.
Right.
Like we've never had close to the same topic.
No,
not at all.
Yeah.
Sarah pick something and then she focuses on it.
Josh me like gum,
Minty Gum,
dust pans pyramid.
Vasco seashells.
Mayonnaise.
Yeah.
Just want to put the crackers.
Yes.
Break it down.
Yeah.
Crack.
That's how she's a third slot.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Easter baskets.
Let's talk about them and I hate him.
Do you think it's tougher
to be a check and do standup comedy?
Ooh,
I like this question.
I think it's,
I think there's two different advantages.
Like think that,
um,
sometimes it's like,
oh,
they only get this stuff because they're girls or you know,
like,
you know,
they,
they flirt their way to stage time or whatever and then at the same time they're
like,
not that many girls.
I mean,
Sarah and I started killed Tony because it was,
you said it was all guy comedians in the beginning and then we became to regular
girls at the end of it.
And it's just,
there's not that much competition right now.
Especially right now.
I feel like there's not a lot of girls in New York.
I know there's a lot more girls,
but I think that it gives us an advantage and like,
I think that if you're funny,
you're funny.
If you work hard,
you work hard.
Yeah.
Those are two definite truth.
If you're funny,
you're funny.
If you work hard,
you work hard,
that's for sure.
But I think that what I've always thought was that,
uh,
we're lucky as men that we could get away with a lot more subject matter.
Like a man can talk about politics and critique like,
like what's going on in the world.
But I think if women start doing that,
like men,
unless they're like really established,
I get,
unless you're like someone that you come to see you do that,
like maybe Janine Garafalo or someone that you go to expect that if an unknown
Gow is on stage and she starts criticizing the current administration,
like who's this fucking know it all bitch,
you know?
Right,
right.
And then like guys,
a lot of guys do not like hearing women like in position of speaking if they
have differing opinions.
You know,
like during like there's a lot of people,
especially men,
they're in this constant state of like a conflict and competition at work.
They're constantly at work,
you know,
battling back and forth with their boss,
dealing with the clients and this and that,
and they're in this constant state.
Then they go to a comedy club and some chick has onstage and she's talking about
the depth,
the difference between the Republicans,
Democrats,
you don't know shit about real public.
Let me guess.
You fucking lived hard,
you know what I mean?
Like they're in this constant state and a woman going on stage.
I think it's a,
it's an extra little hill to climb and then sex is also what I would think is an
extra little hill to climb because it dude can talk about just and all over the
place or you know,
you can talk about basically anything,
right?
But a girl talking about sex,
it gets really tricky.
Like girls a clam up,
they'll,
they'll think you're a whore.
You know,
guys,
you know,
don't know when you know they should laugh or what,
what's acceptable at a chicken.
Get Away with talking about.
Yeah,
I had a lot of trouble with that when I first started because everyone tells you
to talk about your life and I'm 24,
like I'm having sex and like doing this,
you know,
I'm like,
that's my life right now.
And people are like,
Oh,
don't talk about having sex because that's hacky.
That's what all girls talk about.
And it's like,
that's cause we're having sex.
You know,
like you're talking about things you're doing.
Um,
I just say whatever I want.
That's good.
Yeah.
I don't care.
I don't really care.
I just,
my goal is just like,
I feel like as long as I come out of it funny,
if you come out,
if you come out of your set and it was a funny set,
no one's going to be mad at you.
So if he was funny,
they can't be like,
oh,
stupid funny girl.
I mean they can,
but then,
and it's obviously,
it's obvious if you see like Whitney Cummings or Chelsea handler or you know,
even Joan Rivers,
like you could talk about whatever the fuck you want to talk about.
You know,
I just,
I've always felt like as a woman,
like it's probably like there's an extra little hump to crop.
Oh,
they're definitely
feel like ladies are definitely adi ladies in the audience are tougher on women
than they are on guys for sure.
Because almost all you can adjust,
almost see it on their faces.
That's another funny thing about kill Tony,
is we have that perspective where you're sitting at a table facing the audience
and you get to see what they're looking at for a change.
Like instead of just when you're on stage,
that camera one perspective,
you see the looks on their faces sometimes when this type of person's honor,
that type of persons on and women,
it seems like all of them were like,
well,
I know I have to be better than her,
so let's see what she can do.
And then you watch them get beat out of them after a few seconds.
You know?
It's like,
ah,
okay.
I get it.
She's a pro and I don't,
and I judged too quick.
I think there's some women that just are fans of other women.
Totally.
There's some that you love them.
I love women.
Oh,
okay.
Are you met?
You love the women that don't love women?
You know,
like there's some women that only have like male friends.
They don't have any women friends.
Those are the crazy ones.
Are they as crazy as that dude's only have girlfriends?
You know,
my,
my wife had this friend who had a guy friend for like the longest time and I was
like,
that dude is gay.
And they're like,
no,
no.
He's got a kid.
That dude,
he's gay.
No,
he's got a kid.
he's a father.
That dude is gay.
It turns out in his forties that dude is gay.
He's like,
fucking,
I can't carry this anymore.
And I was like,
I told Joe,
Joe,
did he start talking gay media?
It wasn't,
you know what it was,
man,
it was,
there was like,
he was like way too into talking about like girl stuff.
Like he was way too into talking about like shopping and gossip and I was
listening to him talk.
I was like,
what is going on here?
What is this like?
There was this extreme lack of,
of uh,
I mean it wasn't,
it was more like he was like all male woman than it was that he was homosexual
because I never felt like he was hitting on me.
He's a power bottom.
Maybe it's a problem to bottom that fuck it back.
But I'm not saying you never showed any like sexual attraction to men.
He just showed such feminine behavior patterns that I was like,
this is wrong,
this is incorrect here.
Like what's going on?
What's she playing?
They soon split up.
What's up?
Then
the whole thing was a disaster.
But it's just,
it's uh,
it's,
it's fascinating to see someone like that.
It's like battling it,
fighting it off.
The poor bastard just gave in and it's 40.
It's just
nice.
Not like a 20 year old boyfriend bowing
out of the closet and into the funnier
he's flaming get it.
Yeah.
I was hanging out with mostly women,
but I think it's mostly due to my,
like growing up with my mom and my sister though.
But you know,
a lot of dudes are friends with.
Yeah.
But,
but in general,
I like in high school only had girlfriends,
never know guy friends.
And then,
uh,
in,
in real life,
you know,
like most of the time I'm usually hanging out with girls.
I'm not calling up guys going,
hey,
let's go to a bar and get some drinks.
I'm calling up a girl and going,
hey,
let's go to a bar and get some drinks.
I'm never calling guys,
you know,
except for like,
I'm not like,
when was the last time I called him of you guys going to come in here sweating?
I can't handle it
like TMZ and I live in a pink house and Shit.
Hey,
you put that in there.
I saw you slip that in there.
The fuck dude,
the cars.
Have you guys talked at all about all this racial shit that's going on in the
Ferguson riots and talking about any of that on stage?
So deep.
Have you seen that new Ferguson video?
Supposedly,
but it's,
they don't,
they can't verify if it's real or not.
What are you talking about?
It's a,
the guy that got shot,
uh,
him like mugging an old man.
I solid.
It's bullshit.
Is it bullshit?
God?
Cause I Snopes says an unknown.
If it's what makes you think it's bullshit?
Because it doesn't even look like the same guy.
Oh,
it's just like people,
people still think all black guys look the same and it just blatantly show.
It's like,
what the fuck are you saying?
Whoa.
That's what that's saying.
That they don't,
I think
they look a lot alike.
Some of,
Whoa,
some of those.
Some of them,
yes.
Okay.
White people just look very different.
All white people are all like different facial features.
Rude as fuck.
No,
that's not rude.
Why?
People are so,
they all look the same.
I get them confused all the time.
Yeah.
And why people are so different.
Asians look the same.
Puerto Rican women a lot of times with the same whoa will never work in this
town again.
Wow.
How dare you.
Not Racist at all.
I'm just saying like I feel like smell the same way.
I'm just saying like white people are the only ones that look really,
really different all the time.
You don't agree with that?
No.
Oh,
maybe I haven't seen enough people.
You're only 24 kid when you accumulate a database like we have and you want to
see black people with the lights off anyways.
Anyways,
I don't think it's him in the video.
And I think people are just looking for stuff in,
regardless if he wasn't mugging an old man,
the video starts in the middle of a fight.
So you don't know what happens,
right?
So people are just like,
oh,
he's just beating up this old dude.
And it doesn't matter.
It doesn't mean you can kill someone on a sidewalk for selling cigarettes no
matter what they used to do.
You know what I'm most fascinated by with this?
Not even just that it's a,
it seems like weird still stuck when it comes to race relations.
Like we're still stuck in this US versus them mentality.
That just hasn't gone away that
that shocks me.
But what really shocks me is that they just pick this one event and this one
event all of a sudden caught fire and became giant because there's so many of
them.
If you look at the numbers of people,
like there's a,
there's a website that tracks the numbers of people killed by cops every year.
And uh,
like I think it's called cop killer.
Dot.
Something or another.
Somebody tweeted to me today and I was like,
what?
And you,
you look at it like there's like the fact that one just caught on and took off.
It's weird.
Yeah.
But that happens.
It happens.
Like one thing like makes its way to the forefront and then the public grabs a
hold of it and then next thing you know they're out in the street and then for
it to happen.
And then right after that Eric Gardner case happened.
Like,
Whoa,
it's just like out of control.
You know,
it's a tsunami.
Did you see the hashtags
after that whole thing happened?
The climbing wall,
white and living while Black Hashtags,
they're insane.
It's a bunch of white people hashtagging crying while white and admitting to
crimes they've done that.
The police,
like I got pulled over drunk with a gun in my car and the police gave me a ride
home.
And it's like all these things that they're admitting and then the living wall,
black ones were all black people were like,
I went into a store and got questioned.
Right.
And it was like just the difference between,
it was pretty interesting.
I've definitely seen a lot of those living wall black,
you know,
look,
I could see a lot of different sides to this.
The bottom line of all of it is we have to at a certain point in time realize he
can't just keep like letting these poor people in these shit neighborhoods keep
growing up in these neighborhoods and not try to help out.
Right.
And I try to fix that spot.
There's those spots that we have in our country that are like really
impoverished.
Those are critical like errors in our system and we're just sort of like letting
them percolate.
Yep.
Less jail is more education I think.
Fuckable it's also like you could create a bunch of Nice people instead of like
having people grow up,
disenfranchise and fucked up.
You'd have people grow up to contribute to society,
but everyone's got this me or US versus them or you know,
all for one and you know,
like,
we don't have this,
this idea of treating the human race was like,
like a cola.
If we treat treated,
the human race is like an organism,
like one collective Oregon,
a team,
you would say,
okay,
well we've got an issue here.
Let's just clean up this issue and figure out a way to manage everything
together.
Treat it as like one super organism.
That's our country.
One job.
Instead of thinking of it as just a bunch of people living together on a patch
of dirt,
let's think of the human beings.
It's like,
look,
we can't separate from each other unless you're a Weirdo hermit type dude.
This wants to live in the woods.
Everybody's around everybody.
We're all,
we all feed off of each other.
We interact with each other.
We exchange goods,
we exchange services.
I mean we need each other.
We're a part of a team,
whether we like it or not,
human beings,
everybody we were around is a part of our community.
So I think some one,
one of these presidents somewhere along the line is going to have to figure out
a way to,
to say that in a way on television where people listening go,
oh yeah.
So instead of saying,
well,
these welfare moms try to give all these fucking welfare model,
you know,
every baby they have,
they get another check.
Like,
okay,
yeah,
it,
that's not,
this is the least of our worries.
Yeah.
The big worry is this,
more or less people are growing up in this crime ridden neighborhoods and then
they're just growing up and becoming adults and then they go out into the world
and like,
you're dealing with a bunch of human problems.
Yeah.
The worst is really the prison system.
Fuck.
Yeah.
It is.
It's the worst of the worst of the worst of our problems because I bet I've been
working on something recently that us to do with presence and uh,
and uh,
so I found out about how the rest of the world does it and how they completely
can rehabilitate people and get them back in society.
And it's totally the opposite here where the,
you basically create a worse criminal by sending them to prison and then you
send back out again and they have no idea what to do.
Not only that,
they make money off putting him in prison,
which is the most insane thing ever.
This is a,
a large number of private prisons in this country.
And they lobby to make sure that laws are in place that allow them to keep their
prisons full.
Yeah.
And they make all that money that they get from the government and they'll give
the,
the prisoner,
like at the tent city in Arizona,
they eat like 60 cents.
I think their meals are 40 cents per day is what they're feeding the prisoner.
And they brag about feeding the dogs more valuable food during the day.
Like the dog seat,
like 70 cents worth of food per day.
Yeah.
And they make them wear pink.
Yeah,
that's so,
and then they dump them out on the streets when they're done with their sentence
and they don't have a job,
but they don't have good health.
And then they go and rob a store again and again.
It could happen to anybody,
you know?
I mean,
we're going to be in Phoenix.
What?
Tomorrow?
Tomorrow and something could happen.
You know they see Ari and his weird nose.
Do you think they might think he's a terrorist?
Maybe?
No.
Sure.
If we're all together,
I think we'll,
we'll,
we'll tell them.
Luckily,
luckily our,
he wears pink underwear anyway,
so we'll just Google his name and show that he's a hilarious standup comedian.
Look,
sir,
this is a clip from his upcoming comedy central special called paid regular?
Yes.
They're also Aaron,
his other one.
Bearen his other one now.
What was his last one?
Ari's last special.
Passive aggressive.
Yeah.
The cost somewhere in that one too.
Oh yeah.
Civic Hall across a revenge of the Holocaust was a CD.
Did he did these three things out?
Let's got revenge of the Holocaust.
Passive aggressive and then this new one paid regular.
Amazing.
When are you going to release something,
Tony?
Hinchcliffe.
I know you're chomping at the bit.
You hear me talk about Ra and I see a little fucking juices get flying.
Wait.
You get excited and tense.
That's what gives you these panic attacks.
So we give you,
it gives you weird ear pains.
Ah,
I'm going deaf.
No,
you're just freaking the fuck out.
Wait,
we're
waiting for somebody to offer me something.
Okay.
Here's the next question.
When are you gonna quit the cancer sticks?
When,
uh,
when I,
when somebody offers me to shoot a special,
that's what you're going to quit?
Yeah.
And then you'd be like,
I can't quit now to fuck me up.
I need him.
I need him to calm me down while I'm getting ready.
As soon as the specials over.
And then after the specialist over,
you're like,
I gotta write new material.
I can't be thinking about anything other than writing new material.
Once I have a new hour,
then I'm gonna quit the cigarettes.
Yeah.
And then I'm going to get my own TV show and I can't quit smoking then cause I
want to smoke on the TV show.
Bring it back like Carson,
why don't you try cigars?
Cigars.
You don't inhale.
They're supposed to be better for your health.
That's how we'll Phil Hartman quit smoking.
You could be just like Phil,
it's true and I would do that,
but everybody complains about everything.
You know the smell and then this and and that.
Everybody's going to complain no matter what.
That's your look.
That's your sugar.
Shut up.
I'm trying to form a fucking image here.
That's your look dude.
Cigars,
Fedora,
cigar.
Hey guys,
let me fucking talk.
Cowboy.
No,
no,
no.
For Dora,
Bro,
maybe.
Maybe a cowboy hat.
Okay.
Listen.
Vast cowboy hat.
Cigar.
No,
no cowboy hats.
I'm going to work.
I kiss him,
but you look just like woody from toy story.
If he wears a cowboy hat,
here's,
here's the deal.
Three piece suit Mohawk.
Okay.
Three piece suit with a fucking solid Mohawk smoking a cigar on stage.
What happened to all gold?
See gold tie the mastermind.
I could see you with a scarf.
If you wear a scarf,
you're either gay or a cowboy.
You have two options,
right?
Yeah.
Tony,
you look a lot like,
yeah,
you can't be like a straight guy out for a night on the town with a fucking
Bandana around your neck.
Well,
what kind of a guy wears a Bandana around his neck?
Tony in this cartoon,
the guy who wants you to choke them unconscious and fuck him.
Well the guy wants you to squeeze that thing until he blacks out and give them a
good fucking,
there's no other reason for a man unless he's worried about dirt getting into
his neck,
you know?
That's why I better get an audition for woody if that happens.
Do you think there'll be a live action toy story and maybe why would they do
that?
There'll be so dumb.
The kids would be like,
why are we seeing real people?
Where the fuck is woody playing with other adults?
Toy Box.
You'd perfect.
Weird.
Yeah.
You'd be perfect for the twilight zone version when woody comes to life.
Yes.
Yeah.
Like the parents don't see it,
but the kid does and you're giving the kid really fucked up advice and you're
woody.
Yeah.
And the parents come in and all of a sudden you're back to being like a wooden
doll again.
Mommy,
my doll was just smoking a cigarette.
Dude,
I watched,
I binge watched a few of those recently.
Those old school twilight zone episodes the best.
It was so amazing.
You know,
one of the cool things about it is they had so many different subjects to choose
from and they had to do it with a,
like a relatively small budget.
I didn't have much in terms of like special effects.
I'll give you,
go back and look at like some of the old special effects.
They were unbelievably laughable.
Yeah.
I just watched toilet isn't this morning before I really,
which episode was it?
Uh,
the one beauty is only skin deep,
great episode where the girls wants to fix our face.
They don't show it the whole time.
They don't show the doctors' faces either.
And at the end she's like beautiful and everyone's hideous.
Oh Wow.
And they're like,
we're going to send you off with people like you.
And at the end,
it's just like,
she just wanted to be like them.
Oh my God.
Oh,
spoiler alert.
It doesn't matter if they're so awesome.
When the guy was cleaning on the airplane wing.
Yes.
That one was William Shatner.
Cause I'm mad at the wake of this plane.
Amazing.
And the fucking outfit,
the thing hat on was so bad,
so bad.
He was a furry,
it was essentially like a fairy,
like one of those people that goes to those conventions dresses up like a
mascot.
Yeah.
That's what it looked like.
And he slipped,
pretended to be like this like Gremlin John,
like pig Chewbacca picture with John Lithgow was the remake of it.
Yeah.
In the
movie.
Which is really good too.
He's amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Their premise is we're so genius.
There was so many good ones.
My favorite one was to serve man.
Did you ever see that one?
Oh it's the best.
These aliens came down and they,
they brought with them this book and um,
they were going to take people back to their planet and people like it all
signed up to go to their planet.
And the,
the idea of the book was they're going to teach people about all their
technology and how to,
you know,
how to space travel and all that shit.
So they get these people on the ship and as they're hurting them on the ship,
they're all like much bigger than regular people as they're hurting them on the
ship.
The Guy Yells at,
or it's a guy or a girl yells out,
it's a cookbook to serve man.
Like,
you know,
like they thought that the title to serve man was giving man all these
instructions and they deciphered all the different shit and they realize they're
going to eat all these people and so taken off.
They take off of these people in this space share,
but they're going to eat him.
Wow.
It's great.
And it's so Cokie looking like everything is hokey.
This space guys are hooky.
Look into space.
Ship is hokey looking.
Hitchcock holds up to fuck.
Yag does amazing.
Well that's when we were talking about,
um,
like gene wilder and Richard Pryor movies like I,
I almost don't want to watch them to see if they hold up.
But Richard Pryor stand up,
totally holds up.
Totally holds up an undisputed,
undisputed like number one of all time.
Well I think that he was like the most influential,
right?
He was like the most powerful,
he's like changed what comedy is too.
A lot of people like his honesty,
like when he was on fire and Shit,
you know,
it changed what comedy is to people.
Yeah.
I just like when you were talking about sitting in the back of the room and
watching people laugh,
that was like the moment that I ever realized how crazy standup comedy was.
My parents took me to see live in the sunset strip.
I was in the audience.
I was like,
you know,
little kid 13 or something and all these people were like falling down laughing
in the crowd.
And I remember thinking,
I've never seen this before.
I give us a bit,
I've been a lot of comedy movies.
I've never seen anybody fallen down.
And this guy's just talking.
I was like,
I was thinking like,
this is the funniest thing I probably have ever seen.
And he's just talking
crazy.
He's the one.
Yeah.
And that was at the store in the fucking main room.
That's theirs to something weird about that.
Like when you're standing on that stage in that,
in that room and you realize,
Whoa,
this is where Richard Pryor film live on the sunset strip mother.
So cool.
Yeah.
Do you guys uh,
get that like weird charge at a working at the store because of that?
Because of the history behind it all.
Totally cool.
How you're,
how you perceive it.
Like if reception of the store just changes like the money that you hang out
there,
the more that you're immersed in it.
The last weird today is,
and then you bring your normal friends and they're like,
what the hell?
Yeah.
You bring non comedians the store and
they're like,
what is this?
How is this?
Okay.
Why are these people,
how often do you come here again,
this is your home.
What the hell?
Well for Ari,
it really was.
His home are used to walk there.
He lived right up the street.
He lived right next to pink dot.
So he would just walk to his fucking apartment and walked down the store every
day and he was there every day.
That dude lived in that place.
I remember when I first started hanging out there,
someone in the green room called it the island of misfit toys.
I was like,
that's perfect.
Exactly what it is.
Yeah.
I think that was Mitsis term.
I'm pretty sure.
I think it was right.
What do you write in their felony?
Got an idea.
Got something crazy little comedy on the mind.
No,
something funny happened last night though.
I uh,
I was driving home from the,
I are driving to the comedy store from the Ice House and there was an amber
alert on a,
on the radio and the guy had a nicer car than mine.
The abductor,
and I'm like,
this guy needs to get his fucking life together.
2014 Mercedes Benz I'm supposed to be on the lookout for.
Really?
Yeah.
Well yeah,
but it must be really hard to make it in life when you're like a serial killer
or like a child molester or something along those lines,
like struggling with that.
And being super successful.
Yeah.
That's kind of crazy.
That's what I'm thinking.
This guy lives the kind of life where he wanted to be seen in a 2014 Mercedes
Benz and now he's the only guy with a 2014 Mercedes Benz who wants nobody to see
it.
Maybe he only likes kids with tastes.
It's like some American psycho stuff right there.
Yeah,
right.
Well wasn't that the case with the,
there was a guy that was on that show,
seventh heaven.
It turned out he was molesting girls like young girls like that.
I mean obviously that guy get a Mercedes.
Right?
I mean it's,
sometimes people do get super wealthy while being sex criminals.
Yeah.
Such a crush on him.
When I was younger did June,
he could've gotten it for probably the dad from seventh heaven.
How old?
How old do you think you would have to be before you would give it up to him?
Oh my God.
When I was watching [inaudible] was watching it when I was like 12 or 13 four
and if you had met him at that time,
wouldn't have fucked him cause I wasn't like a whore 14 year old.
Right.
But would would,
do you think that you would have been like interested in hanging around with
them?
I was obsessed with them.
I was like so good dad from seventh.
I was obsessed with him.
I kind of liked him too on the show.
Seventh Heaven.
Yeah.
So you guys were children.
You guys were fans of seven.
I used to watch it in like fifth grade.
I've seen every episode and I watched him again.
I'm not going to lie like four months ago.
Whoa,
whoa.
That's how I learn what huffing was because one of them,
so was how you were saying
that's when you know you uh,
you fucking have fucked up beyond fucked up when they were arresting you,
you got paint all over your face.
Paint on his face.
No huffing.
No.
Oh yeah.
That shit's,
people just get caught huffing.
If you've seen those photos of dudes,
there's this one dude just looks method out of his mind,
like silver paint all over his nose and his lips and his mouth and you're like,
oh my God,
dude,
welcome to this is,
this is the bottom.
Just hit the bottom.
It doesn't go anywhere from here,
but up.
That's some of the best episodes of cops too,
when they always catch the guys with the silver,
but it's something about,
I wasn't doing nothing.
Officer don't shows that appeals to like younger people.
That would look a little bit more innocent,
right?
Yeah.
Now I watch it.
I'm like,
Whoa,
that was a mister rack.
Like I thought I was learning so much.
I'm like,
I'm in the world and learning about huffing and ready.
It's great.
Let's go.
That's how I learned a lot of stuff.
Dump show.
That's one of the things you don't like as an adult.
You don't always piece it together like this show is awesome.
If you're 12 you know?
Yeah,
it's stupid as fuck when you're 15 but when you're 12 it's awesome.
When you 30,
you can't watch that,
but when you're 12,
it gets you just,
it hits a certain tone inside of you.
It's like the costumes in the twilight zone and you're like,
how did I think this was scary?
But that was a long time ago,
you know?
Wow.
This seventh Heaven Guy,
like that show was all about like a preacher,
right
in his family.
He's the preacher.
He was a preacher in the show.
Yeah.
Maybe he was just doing research for his role.
I just found a great video of this paint huffer and series of his,
uh,
over 14 years of his,
his mugshots.
Oh,
good Lord.
And it's a,
it starts off 14 years.
Guy Roast battle does look like someone pretty crazy.
2009,
whoa.
Later in 2009,
he didn't look so good.
Oh my [inaudible] in the Ronald McDonald.
Every time they were arresting him,
he's got silver in his face.
He likes that color of March,
2009.
February,
2000.
Why are they going back and forth?
Rowdy Roddy huffer over.
It doesn't make any sense.
They went from March to a breakout or something going on?
Yeah.
What does he get?
Clumps in his beard.
All paint his beard,
but this is going backwards.
This is February.
This is going January.
Like how is it going backwards?
It's such a bad huffing problem,
but this is weird because it's not showing like a progression.
It's showing a regression.
Oh,
okay.
But that's 2008 back in time backwards.
Just to show you how long he's been doing it.
He actually looks better because of huffing paint,
I think in huffing paint might be actually good for this dude.
He's like,
you don't get it.
Oh my God.
They busted him huffing paint.
2000 and 5,003 was huffing paint
all over his face.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Oh Jeez.
Eight first busted in [inaudible] 98 why?
He was like,
Whoa,
what's that?
He's the captain and anneal.
This guy looks so different.
He could be an actor.
It's going to end on [inaudible]
95 I feel like we should do a documentary around that guy.
Give Him all the painting,
wants it,
faces of death.
Ask him what he feels about life.
Give them like certain subjects and ask him to expound.
Yeah,
just film for like 10 hours and you can get 40 minutes of wisdom out of that.
Do you think he started with sharpies and then he graduated?
I remember as a kid just sniffing sharpies.
Yeah.
Get them right up to my nose.
Just,
Yup.
Yeah.
Especially those fat ones.
The fact silver ones.
Yeah.
The best.
What is it about certain smells like that?
Gasoline.
So what it is,
it's the best.
No,
it's just that gasoline.
The smell of alcohol,
like rubbing alcohol.
Right.
But what is it about those smells that like attracts people?
Because it's like you want to keep it.
We all love it so hard.
Everybody does.
Yeah.
I'd never met anybody who doesn't like the smell markers.
Do you like smell Marcus?
Jamie?
Yes.
He says,
yeah,
he's got a marker right there.
He's practicing Brian.
I,
yeah,
but I used to hate the smell of skunks,
but now as a pot smoker,
I love skunks.
I loved the smell of shut downs when I was let off.
That's interesting.
Do you know that it was explained to me or I read it somewhere actually that
the,
when you smell skunk smell,
that's how good a dog's nose is,
is that skunk is such a particularly strong smell that you could smell it and
like just a few parts per million in the air.
That's why like you can be driving on the street and you could smell a skunk
that's nowhere near your car,
right?
It's like nowhere near,
not even a hundred feet from your car and you smell a skunk.
How the fuck can you smell it?
It's gone.
Well that's how a dog is with everything.
That's why dogs can like find dudes that are like running through the woods by
sniffing their socks.
They're like sniff the guys sock.
They get a set and they go off like they just,
they just,
just like,
you could smell a skunk like,
oh,
it's over here.
It's over here.
Like you know like roughly as you're walking in the street,
if you're getting closer to where that skunk is,
which is incredible.
If you think about,
there's no other smell like that for us.
We're just such a small amount.
Maybe they'll stink.
Bomb things.
Remember those fucking things they used to throw in school?
Oh yeah.
The little Capri Sun bags of us.
Think those little things.
Well,
there will,
when I was a kid,
they were like these little glass vials and they would throw them in the ground,
shadow them and the whole school,
it's just stink.
One asshole threw him in the ventilation system of the air conditioning system.
That's all right.
Yeah.
He fucked the entire room up like the,
the whole class had to get evacuated.
It was so bad.
Like he just thrown it into the system,
went out into the hallways.
It's,
everybody was gagging.
We didn't have stink bombs.
But one time a girl threw up fruit roll up next to me and I can still smell it.
It smells good fruit roll ups for me for forever.
Yeah.
I guess when you get a,
um,
when someone throws up around you,
your immediate instinct is to throw up because like,
it could be that it's food poisoning and that you react to that you all ate the
same food and you realize that they're getting sick and before your body can
digest it,
you just,
your body goes,
oh,
this is bad food.
So if you smell someone puking,
you just start
Puca.
Yeah,
that's,
that's amazing.
I love that stuff,
that natural,
uh,
like what's the one with,
um,
like women and like if you smell a woman and,
and uh,
like there's like a stink that you like,
then that means that you're like far genetically
apart.
Like a bad wiper.
Exactly.
Fairmont.
What are you saying is that you have different genes?
You're not related in any way,
so it makes them more attractive.
Yes.
So it'd be good to breed with that person.
Right,
right.
Which is amazing,
but that throw up on,
that's a great one.
I've always wondered why that is,
but I always wondered,
you know,
whether or not certain levels of diversity is attracting attractive to people at
sexual diversity.
Just because of like your genetics want to mix things up.
You know what I mean?
Like a lot of guys have Asian fetishes or maybe Norwegian fetishes like blondes,
they're like big blondes.
You know what I mean?
Like people get these [inaudible] and like what is that?
It's like,
well you want to introduce those genes into your genes and just like push that
new system out there.
That's the combination because if you make close to your genes then yeah,
it could end up to formed or whatever.
Yeah.
Like it's very rarely see like an all blonde couple blonde guy,
blond girl.
Well nothing wrong with loving blondes,
but you have dark hair.
So it's kind of like,
makes sense,
right?
Like so nineties like blondes mean girls.
I just like bonds like one guys.
Do you ever go to the beach and go a surfer trolling or something?
More dudes at Surf Blonde.
Okay,
there you go.
Cause that's a fucking stereotype right there.
That is a surfer dudes are kind of dopey.
You would assume they're blondes.
Hey,
what's up?
Didn't I see you on like a leeches?
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
but you assume they're idiots.
I do.
Yeah.
Right.
And bleaches their brain to,
yeah,
like a guy with a nice blonde hair.
It will probably never be president.
What's his Fox News anchors?
You Know Sandy,
it's gotta be saying,
I wonder is there anything like did the stereotype of dumb blondes is a very
common stereotype?
What is in that?
What's that about?
Is that just that we men prefer blondes so some bonds don't have to work as hard
because they're blonde.
Or is there some weird link between having like light hair and lower
intelligence?
I think it's a little bit of both.
There must be some blonde geniuses though.
Yeah,
I think it's a cultural thing.
I really,
I like,
yeah,
like surfer Dude Valley girl.
That's what I picture blonds like pop culture went a little bit overboard and
that's what everyone thinks of now.
Look bonds more rich white women and they're the ones that are at home
like with handbags and like,
I think that's what it,
that's where it came from.
Rich white women in their fucking hands.
Yeah.
Am I getting really racist at all?
No,
not at all.
The part where you said every race looks alike was perfect.
Yeah.
So except white people.
Right.
Um,
but yeah,
jelly,
the blonde thing,
like at the playboy level,
like playboy playmates were all blonde for a while.
Like that was the stereotypical playboy playmate,
right.
Blonde,
blue eyes.
Right.
Like how'd that happen?
Like what,
what is the best
Hugh Hefner just being,
uh,
a fetishist.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like Mitzi,
they used to say that Mitzi hated blondes because she was a Brunette and she was
the queen of the comedy store.
So like,
I guess it was like impossible for a blonde girl that even not only not get
passed at the store,
but it was hard for them to get waitressing jobs at the store.
I've missed,
he just had this horse and all the cute little brunettes everywhere.
But
yeah.
Well Dude,
you know like people like Mitzi shore,
like really like harsh,
like very eccentric people.
Like one person like that in an ecosystem can change the entire,
like,
like with comedy,
one person like her change comedy would be realistic.
Like that club and like her contributions and her insistence on keeping it
crazy.
Yeah.
The,
all the madness that she would do.
She would take comics that don't like each other and she put them back to back
with each other.
So they had to introduce each other always.
Oh.
And all that shit that she did.
Like letting the comics run that place.
Yeah,
the loan it takes run the asylum,
you know,
she,
she created like this whole like comedy movement.
If you think about all the,
the guys that came out of that place Kennison and prior and like,
you know,
Letterman list goes on and on and on.
Man.
A lot of it because that one lady,
no,
Wendy and in Denver,
where are you going to be?
January,
but the January 2nd and third.
Oh good Lord.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Tony Hinchcliffe comes to Denver all weekend long.
Golden Pony triumphantly rides into town during the fucking part of the winter.
God,
Lord,
that'd be cool.
Little bit.
Tony,
warm your heart.
That's the pony riding into Denver.
That's the thing about Denver.
Even when it's cold,
it's sunny out.
It's not even depressing.
It's just cold.
Yeah.
When they went,
I was there with you.
Uh,
and when you did your taping,
there was some amazing fun facts on the wall like that.
It has more sunny days than San Diego and stuff like that.
That dude,
it's,
it's sunny.
It's fuck.
Yeah.
It's one of the coolest cities on the planet earth.
Denver.
Absolutely.
One of the best spots ever,
and now with the weed and fusion,
that place is out of town.
They're just going crazy.
Yeah,
there's,
apparently they passed it.
They pass legal weed in Washington DC.
I don't know what you've seen that,
but there's some new
challenge to it by this,
a local politician who's being paid off a congressman who's being paid off by
pharmaceutical companies.
This guy named Harris from Maryland.
He just led the charge to overturn the will of Washington DC voters by inserting
language into Congress,
spending bill that prevents a district from implementing the referendum.
They passed to legalize recreational marijuana and the 2014 midterm election,
the referendum,
by the way,
passed with 70% of the vote on election day.
So this hunt,
he introduced language into a bill sneakily stopping this from passing when 70%
of the population want it.
And when they asked him about it,
he said that relaxing marijuana laws clearly leads to more teenage drug use,
which is just a lie.
That's just not true.
It's just not true.
According to Gallup,
polls obviously pulls her full shit,
but marijuana use amongst 18 to 20 wine,
nine year olds has fallen 20% since 1985 so even though we'd is way more
accessible than ever before,
it's continued to drop because it's not a sneaky now.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's not as thrilling because it's like everyone's smoking.
We all know that effect.
People don't like people telling them what to do.
Exactly.
You know,
tell your kids what to do.
They're going to rebel.
The cops.
Kids always want to being criminals are doing something fucking crazy.
I dated a girl in high school that was went to Catholic school.
Yeah.
Oh you dirty girl.
I wouldn't shut it.
Only want to hear anymore.
I went to Catholic school too.
Did you?
Yeah,
the girls.
It's really,
I'd imagine regular here moving a all girls.
No,
it's tough though man.
I'm telling Ya because that's hard to go to school with girls wearing skirts and
the girls were all super cute and they'd roll their skirts up and I remember,
Hey I,
I had a boner like eight hours a day going to school.
You'd have to try to like settle it down before the,
before class would end just because you had to walk,
it was a big school,
three floors and you'd have to take the stairs so you couldn't have the boner in
between classes.
So you'd have to like focus on other things like your school work for the last
couple of minutes to get the bone or away.
Those 1617 year old boners are so different to oh they have just throbbing,
throbbing and they're re relatively recent in your life.
So they're incredibly confusing.
Like if you're 30 and you've been getting boners since you were 15 that's
normal.
It seems like,
oh well here's a boner again,
I know how to deal with this.
But when you're 15 you're like,
oh,
I don't know what to do.
You're so confused.
Like the power it has over your system is you are dealing with millions of years
of DNA that's telling you to breed and you're trying to find someone to do this
with.
It's all going on be internally like behind the scenes,
but socially and culturally you're your face with repression and
slut shaming and worry and fear of pregnancy and fear of disease.
And there's all this shit going on that confuses this like natural weird thing
that your body is going through.
Your body just wants to fuck you know when you're 16 that I remember that being
so confusing,
like relatively like having a relatively good control over my life until I
started getting boners.
And then you know,
you wind up be like,
what the fuck?
Like who am I?
But I remember specifically is how much more powerful the Boehner was that like
not only does a throb but it also,
I don't know if this happened with you guys,
but mine would stick just like straight up.
It's not like it is now where like if it,
if it happens then it's just a boner.
But it would be like star pointed more northward like a fucking compass or
something.
You can go back there with a boner pills.
Well and were confused at why teachers are having sex with 17 year old boys.
They have throbbing dicks.
Oh my God.
Well I mean someone's sounds like they want to fuck some kids.
No.
Yeah,
I get it.
Yeah.
If you or your husband is like barely hard and there's some 16 year old kid,
it's just rock cars flash putting his leg to this side.
Yeah.
You're seeing the outline of it in his pants.
He has to talk to you about football practice and I just get so confused during
football practice and it's a waste line.
A lot of time something happens in my legs get numb and that's where you have to
hide it.
You have to hide it up top.
You can't go any other direction with that.
You have to go along the belt and like pull your shirt out a little bit.
Untuck the shirt or you got to get into sweatshirts.
Right.
Long ones,
they're a little bit too long for you.
They'd go down,
they'd cover,
cover your package and then you have to carry your books in front of it all.
Yeah,
regulating kids.
Having sex is one of the most ridiculous things ever are trying in any way to
regulate kids or it's stopped them.
Then when they're trying to pull that,
push that abstinence like that's the best.
Abstinence is the best way to deal with sex with children.
Just keep them from having sex.
Abstain,
abstain,
abstain.
It's like saying don't eat to hungry people.
It's like getting hungry people and putting in a room full of food and saying,
don't eat.
That's how babies are made.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
But not telling them like,
look,
you know,
wear a condom or get on the pill.
Like something needs to happen here.
You guys can't just be shooting loads of each other.
You're 15 can't make kids.
You know,
you could if we were living 10,000 years ago and nobody had invented schools
yet.
But that's the other thing about schools,
it's like we take kids and we take them away from the people that they're
learning from,
which is adults and we stick them with mostly other kids and a couple parents or
rather adults that barely can control the room.
So that becomes as Lord of the flies type situation.
Like almost immediately when you get more than 30 kids in a classroom.
And most classrooms today because of budget cuts like fucking 40 people and shed
40 kids in the class.
One teacher,
good luck control and those little animals,
good luck.
And then they just start
fucking each other,
right?
A little while.
Monkeys,
Whoa,
stop them.
They're having parties.
Parents are going out of town.
It's fucking banging each other and going nuts.
The band kids where the horniest band.
God.
Yeah.
Well you were so horny.
I don't know.
They were all fucking each other all the time.
Hi.
This sounds like the most awesome opening to like a porn girls describing her.
It was always the band kid.
She goes back to our memory.
It's like a younger,
Kim was like a camp outfit on Tuba.
Where are you guys going?
Why are you going to hike with all your instruments?
Where we're going to go play over in this field?
Do you want to come?
Yeah.
You'd come over the top of the crest.
The hill and it's just dope.
Fucking orgy.
Just to buzz.
Yeah.
Gang brains and fucking,
I like the thought of someone just having a triangle that just came for the sex.
Yeah.
Some do with fucking Morocco's.
Yeah,
right guys.
So are we doing this or was,
what are those things?
Stumbles.
Not Assemble.
What are those?
The assemble tambourine.
Tambourine.
That's an asshole instrument.
If you choose a tambourine,
if you'd like,
I'd take a tambourine,
well,
you just want to annoy people.
Right?
And they're like to marine.
It can make certain songs have a little depth,
but if that's all you got,
you're an asshole.
Yeah.
I'll give you show up and you're like doing a like on the side of the street
doing a street performer thing and it's with a tambourine good luck bitch.
You're going to starve to death.
Yeah.
Let me just give you money to annoy him.
What the fuck?
His stupid tamber Brody Stevens.
I love Brody.
He always has that tambourine kick his fucking around.
Brody Stevens.
You know what he does do though?
That's hilarious.
He plays drums on chairs.
If you ever seen Brody do that.
Oh yeah.
He's really good at the drums,
so bust out chairs for drums and just start playing.
I'm like,
he's playing drums and go off like it's real.
Did it do?
Yeah.
That's one of those late night old school,
original room comedy store set type things.
You know,
you see him doing that takes great pride in inventing the art of chair drumming.
Yeah.
Brody Stevens,
another one at the commissary.
Is there anybody that does the tambourine well,
I guess they're like the lost art of the tambourine fought.
See if you can find awesome
Maureen performance.
Not Try that way.
You never know.
Somebody might know how to rock it,
right?
Yes.
Somebody's mind.
Yeah.
I've thought that before.
I remember putting a tweets.
Has Anyone ever really mastered the tambourine this thing?
You're just thinking about it.
How would you know?
We'd have to go look,
right?
Yeah.
Do you remember like school plays when they did the musicals and they gave all
the shitty kids?
That one little thing,
thing,
xylophone.
They gave the shitty kids that couldn't play in the musical.
They're like,
you just tap this one.
You know what's really funny when you're like for that thing is to shit dope as
fuck.
All kids gravitate towards that.
It's a trap because there's not a lot of longevity in the xylophone.
Like you start,
you start out thinking,
yeah,
I'm a fucking head of the curve.
Yeah,
but you got to know when to bail on the,
that's just bongos,
dude.
That's the tambourine in between his legs.
Oh,
no way.
Yeah,
he made it an art.
Oh his hair's
so that's the guy that was huffing.
Uh,
he's actually playing the drums though.
I don't understand.
That's the tambourine is making the drum sound as well,
right?
Yeah.
I'm counting on the top of the temporary.
Pretty okay.
I have to take it back cause that's pretty dope.
You don't like it.
Does that count as playing?
Just the tambourine?
Yeah,
he's using the tambourine but not play itself.
No,
that is,
that's the tambourine tambourine.
He has an in between his legs instead of holding it like you normally see it.
I could see like a wild,
crazy eccentric man.
It has.
Is his bedroom done up like a jungle at any brings you in and lazy
John on a Hammock and then he puts this this CD on and it's all just this guy
playing jungle tambourine music and the guy comes down,
we'll look fucking feathers around his wrist and shit.
Some wild boar.
Your head dress on.
He fucks this kind of music.
Yeah.
You couldn't see this.
Oh,
I can totally picture that.
I could see you doing that Tony.
Well,
you know,
I've been known the bus stop.
A tambourine for sure.
Time to time.
I don't see playing it.
I see you putting that music on the background showing up with like face paint
on this war path.
Whoa.
Yeah.
This is actually seen from less the chick from bedrooms,
right?
That's Mama from good times,
Huh?
If church was like that long ago,
Trish,
for black people's way better than church for white people,
Gary Owens is a whole bit about it.
They turn up,
turn up,
turn up for what they turn up or turn down for water and I'm for Jesus her down
for what?
You see that video turn down for what?
A fucking little John Video.
It's the greatest music video in the history of the world.
Brian counts sent it to me.
He goes,
this is the greatest thing you'll ever watch your life.
And I was like,
are you really making me watch a little John Video?
And then halfway into it I realized,
oh my God,
it's the greatest thing I've ever seen in my life.
Turn down for what?
He's great.
It's a wild motherfucker.
New Mountain Dew Dorito flavor.
That's the students to do.
We
see a guy like a little John is a perfect example.
Why everybody shouldn't like take a standard path through life.
You know,
high school,
College,
get your shit together.
Four O one k plan.
No,
no,
no.
You d like in order for a dude to have diamonds all over his teeth and be some
crazy motherfucker,
you need to have an eccentric childhood.
You know,
you need to have a,
uh,
a very unusual path and upbringing.
You know,
you don't just make a little John.
He is so cool in real life.
I hung out with him.
We had a crazy night in Nashville.
We both have a mutual friend who flew us out for his birthday party,
like this blowout 50th birthday party for John Rich big musician.
And uh,
I roasted him.
He flew me,
Jeff Ross and Sarah Tiana to his 50th,
well his wife did to roast him.
He has like a house of Blues in his house.
He has a big five story house on a mountain in Nashville.
John Rich Shit.
So and I roasted a,
I roasted lulled John too cause he was out in the audience but I had to,
you know,
I had to acknowledge them.
Right,
right,
right.
And uh,
did you have a song?
What else is on when he's in the audience?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He had everything.
He had the whole look I go nowadays when Lil Jon is yelling what?
It's because he's gotten old and he couldn't hear you.
Huh?
The sunglasses.
That's the,
if you were on $25,000 pyramid,
that would be under things only black people can wear at night.
Sunglasses.
You would,
that would be like one of the first ones.
Black people in Bondo.
That's it.
You but Bondo.
I had to say that he had glaucoma cause people are like what the fuck?
Bano yeah,
you're always wearing sunglasses but black people can just get away with it.
And Floyd Mayweather every interview he does,
he wear sunglasses,
he gets interviewed,
does award shows,
wear sunglasses,
walks up to the deus with sunglasses on and no one says anything.
If a white guy tried to do that,
can you imagine if like,
okay,
like a famous white boxer like Vladimir Klitschko heavyweight champion.
If he showed up with sunglasses on and they're like,
that motherfucker isn't even train and he went Hollywood.
Yeah.
Look at him.
White guys wearing like sunglasses indoors or at night shows a lack of
dedication to your craft.
Right?
It looks a lot douchey or when white guys do it,
I think,
why is that what it feels like the right like rock and roll vibe.
Then maybe you could work Elvis keeping it around David Lee Roth can do whatever
the fuck he wants to tell you that right now.
Like a rock and roll vibe.
It works the way I call it David.
The Rock can do whatever the fucking lost Schaefer with Joe Perry when we had
Joe Perry and Joe Perry could do whatever the fuck you want slash slash can do
whatever the fuck he wants.
Axl rose though.
If he's wearing sunglasses,
you're like,
you're high bitch.
Me John was,
that was Paul Paul Shaffer.
He could basically do whatever the fuck he wants.
Yeah,
he's eccentric.
He's allowed to.
Elton John told him he used to wear those glasses.
Can do anything.
That's the one exception.
Every fucking roll.
Huh?
You could wear a wig,
put on crazy glasses.
He can fucking wear silly hats.
You can do anything you want to Rod Stewart,
wear glasses.
He could do whatever the fuck he wants.
He wrote Maggie Mae.
This is like if you get one wake up Maggie song in your life,
you know that song just knocked it out of the fucking park.
He's,
he's done for life.
He's always rod Stewart.
Yeah.
No matter where he goes to the rest of his life.
That's Rod motherfucker store.
Me Too.
When I was 15 and I didn't appreciate it.
So we left early.
Oh No.
Yeah.
We didn't even wear like this fucking is weird.
He's wearing weird pants.
Let's get outta here.
You definitely,
where were pants?
Yeah.
And it was just like all these older people like dancing in the front and we're
like,
he's moody,
like angry teenagers that their bangs to the side.
Oh
that song is so God damn good.
He's got a bunch of songs that are so gap.
God damn good.
But then he went like disco later.
Yeah,
you got it.
Like that disco phase.
You know the early shit is like my favorite shit of his,
but then he got like,
he got that sexy song.
Yeah.
Few bought my body started looking like a bird.
It just wasn't the same shit.
You know,
it's like that was like,
it was more of a lego lower frequency than the old,
like Maggie Mae's like this deep rich storytelling song.
And we know when that song resets three fourths of the way through and that
mandolin comes through.
If you don't get the chills,
kill yourself.
I like a song about a chick fucking up a dude's life too.
I liked that.
I like hearing those songs.
I support that.
Yeah.
Do you girls find it's hard to date guys cause they wear,
you put them in their act,
your act or other,
no,
they're just not as funny to me because guys try to impress girls by being
funny.
Right.
And I'm constantly around the funniest and so I'm just like,
Ooh,
this is terrible.
It's off,
right?
Yeah.
It's weird situation.
Cause then it sometimes I'm like,
oh,
maybe I should just wait like a bank teller and then I'm like,
this is so boring and lame.
And then you know,
you don't want to date someone that's always busy.
Like you said,
it's like date yourself,
wasn't it?
There's also the weird thing about,
um,
comedians is that you guys go on stage.
I mean,
we all go on stage like pretty much every night.
So every night like you like,
you know,
they're like,
hey,
let's go do this and go to Napa.
You're like,
I've got to do a set.
Yeah.
You know,
especially like when you're really like right now,
like how you are right now,
right.
How I am right now,
where you're in the middle of like a bunch of new bits and were like super
excited about all these new bits.
Those you gotta you gotta feed those bitches every day.
Like you can't just let them say you have a new bit.
You can't put that fucker on the shelf at all.
Right?
You got to jump on it and keep watering it.
Nobody wants to hear that shit if you're dating them.
Oh,
you care about is your fucking jokes.
Just want to go to the comedy club and make a bunch of dudes laugh.
Is that what it is?
Fucking cute up there.
Yeah.
Is Your Dick Paying me?
What if they said yeah,
yeah.
No pain.
Which pay?
What's a bitcoin?
Apparently there's a Toyota dealership that just started accepting bitcoin for
payment for fucking cars in Palm Beach,
Florida and Microsoft start accepting bitcoin.
Microsoft started to invent a accepting bitcoin for their APP,
their APP APP,
whatever it is.
Store they call the store market at market,
whatever the fuck it is.
Nice.
I don't even get it.
Me Neither.
Is it kind of take off?
Is it worth learning about?
Yes.
Yeah.
If you listen to this podcast with a,
um,
Andrea has Antonopoulos this guy that we had on,
we found him on three times and every time he talks I get more and more
convinced and the Fizz,
the third last third latest podcast,
I'm like,
this shit actually has a chance and cause half list.
Yeah.
Isn't that the Brown elephant from Sesame Street?
I'm a grown man.
That's different.
That's the guy you never see.
Yeah.
Snuffaluffagus he never say Antonopoulos he's been on the podcast times.
Oh,
okay.
Pay attention span.
Anyway.
Um,
he's,
he's convinced in the,
in the value of digital currency.
He's absolutely convinced and convincing.
He's a brilliant guy.
So when he talks about it and he's as knowledgeable about Bitcoin,
has anybody explains the algorithm behind creating it and he explains like why
it's viable and why companies jumping on board.
Paypal uses it now.
Dell computers uses it now.
Tiger direct uses it now.
I mean,
it's getting to the point where popup up,
boop,
boop.
Companies just up and up are starting to use it.
And if it becomes an accepted form of currency,
boy that's going to get really weird.
It didn't even exist three years ago.
So you gotta think like three,
four,
five years ago,
there was no bitcoin.
Right?
So what is it gonna be like five years from now if you could
buy a car with it today?
Wow.
Yeah.
I saw an ATM,
a Bitcoin ATM and Hollywood and I was like,
what is that?
What is that?
Yeah.
What the fuck is that going to be able to adopt kids with bitcoins?
Does the thing be paid or adopt kids?
Do you have a plan to buy them with bitcoins?
No.
To like never have a kid just to adopt one,
but that way you pay for it.
Oh No,
I need to have a kid.
I think my plan is to marry like someone that's down to be like a house dad.
I've been like let me make money and you want to marry a bitch?
No.
Like he needs to be mainly too like you can check off what in the yard by the
way.
I'm joking.
Did,
if you're a house dad,
you're a bitch.
No,
the the traditional roles of a mother and father and uh,
you know,
like I have a friend who's essentially a house mom.
His wife has his very high powered job and he's a professor at Stanford.
He teaches like a couple of days a week,
but other days he's home.
He's,
he saw him all the time with his kids and he's the one who's around them all the
time
and it works.
That's part,
that's one of those hard parts about being a woman comedian too and like wanting
a family because where you have a biological clock and I'm also working,
it's like Manhattan,
take their time and get,
establish and be 70 year old millionaire and then find some like hot young girl
to impregnate.
But we have like a,
we have to do it like now it's like now or never.
Yeah,
yeah.
You have to trick a guy quick,
full.
Like
how rude.
You don't agree Sam.
I'll fucking rude.
I feel like,
who wants to feel like the old data misses like their kids stuff?
The dads with like millions and millions of dollars.
I'm thinking like that.
They're just being selfish.
Probably.
You know,
when you see like a 65 year old guy who has a kid,
they're not thinking,
you know,
like,
boy,
uh,
I know I'll be here 40 years from now when I'm 105 this kids set and I'm going
to be in his life.
No,
they're just having a kid.
Yeah.
I mean maybe it's good.
Maybe it's bad.
You know,
who knows?
I mean,
I think that's the thing about human beings.
He's like even under less than ideal circumstances,
a lot of times cool people come out of it.
Yeah.
It's a real dilemma involved in raising kids because you want to protect your
kids,
but the reality is adversity builds character and meeting weird people,
shitty people mean people like it gives you like a database to draw from.
And then the other thing,
we've talked about this before,
but being around people who are kind of shitty makes you appreciate people who
are really cool.
What are you doing with your hand gestures?
10 minutes.
Okay.
I wasn't sure it was behind me.
And then you smelled your own arm.
And then I smelled my microphone and caught a whiff and was like,
oh,
it's just me.
Oh,
good Lord,
Lord.
Um,
so kill Tony is on the desk quad podcast network.
It's on pretty much,
you guys do it once a week,
right?
I mean,
the comedy store every Monday night at eight,
every Monday night live the comedy store.
If somebody wants to get tickets,
did they buy them in advanced?
Do they get them at the door reservations online?
Or You could just economy store's website.
Yeah.
So go to [inaudible] dot com and a desk,
squad.tv for all the links to all the podcasts and audio,
video and audio,
and a also tour schedule for all the Brian shows,
all the ones that you do with Tony.
And I mean,
you're constantly doing stuff on the road.
You got some shit coming up,
right?
And we have a good one.
Next Wednesday.
We're having a benefit show at the comedy store.
Uh,
Jeff Ross is,
he's probably going to do it.
We end and Kim might actually be roasting,
doing a quick roast at the beginning.
Uh,
because all the money is going towards buying a new sound system in a,
in the belly room where kill Tony's recorded and where the roast battles
recorded.
Uh,
so,
uh,
you gotta check it out at Joe.
Joe Said,
you're said you're going to do it also and yeah,
I'm going to do it also.
I'm Secura and that's going to be great.
We're going to get all new speakers in the belly rooms at the live shows better.
Yes.
Shows taking place on that right now.
It's all going through.
You would never believe it if you looked at it for the energy that's in those
rooms during roast battle and kill Tony,
it's all coming through to little tiny like bathrooms,
speakers,
how much the speakers cost.
I don't know.
W W W I told the general manager was just go in there,
you know,
knew cause they need a new sound board.
Also the soundboards just as shitty sound byte.
It's been destroyed a thousand times.
And so just to get a quote and then whatever it is,
we'll just put it towards whatever.
That sounds dope.
So we can maybe do a few shows if you don't make the money in one show.
Yeah.
Do a few shows.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I think that's what it is.
My friends.
So that's the 17th
right?
Yeah,
the 17th eight 30 a comedy Stuart's Cami,
store.com.
That's a Wednesday too,
right?
Wednesday,
December,
December 17th that day I have Ron Finley on the podcast.
He's that guy that's growing a farms in uh,
in La,
in the inner city.
He's doing like these urban farms or he's helping people grow their own food and
these like abandoned lots and teaching them how to grow healthy,
nutritious food in like Compton and watts and shit like that in Inglewood.
It's really bad ass.
Something that we've been talking about for a long time.
Like,
like people like,
like the cost of food,
like how difficult it is to like get food and like why don't we have like
community farms where like the whole block is responsible for like one,
one area where we all grow vegetables and we all get the food from that and we
distributed evenly amongst each other.
This guy's doing that.
Amazing.
Yeah,
he's got a Ted talk on it,
so he's going to be there,
uh,
on the podcast that same day.
Okay,
cool.
Very cool indeed.
Anything to add?
Toner,
Denver,
Denver.
I love coming.
Wendy is the best.
And she told me that,
that I'm headlining.
I can't even believe it.
So please come see me January 2nd and third.
It's a really big deal for him.
Yeah.
And uh,
Tony will be with me tomorrow night.
We will be together with Young Ari Shaffir Aka the renegade Jew super twink and
the renegade Jew at the celebrity theater in Phoenix.
The celebrity theater spins in a circle.
It's like a theater in the round,
which is pretty interesting.
Um,
and people get to look at your ass.
We're on stage and I'm so excited to call it that.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to stuff it with the toilet paper or something.
Oh,
I thought you were gonna say like CIA style.
They were stuffing people's asses with food.
Do you hear about that?
Oh yeah.
You're actually feeding them to get them to give up information.
I'll tell you what,
I'm never more truthful than when you're shoving crackers into my ass.
Yeah.
That's when I really come with the truth.
I'll rat out anybody sense like what kind of an asshole?
I guess the only way you can fucking get that guy to talk to guy in his ass.
So on a ritual.
Oh No,
not that cucumber.
Obama's.
Hmm.
All right.
Uh,
all right,
so we will be back podcast wise.
We'll be back on Monday,
my friends.
So until then,
go fuck yourself.
Have A,
have a beautiful life.
A hug your kids.
Pet your cat.
Uh,
tomorrow night.
See you guys in Phoenix.
Oh,
um,
Twitter pages.
Ladies.
Uh,
at Kim.
Really Congdon spell that shit.
A c.
O n g.
D.
O N.
Kimberly.
And you have a,
an odd or one mine is Princess Shank is so princess like normal.
And then another ass of three houses in a row.
H e n k,
Sarah wine shank and Kimberly Condon,
renegades of comedy warriors of joke telling kill Tony on the desk squad that
work.
All right,
coach,
kill Tony Pod.
Also kill Tony Pod.
Okay.
All right.
We love you guys and we'll see you soon.
Bye.